Eles me escutam bem.
Canto está melhor aí.
Rapaz. Eu passei o dia todo sem falar. Vamos ver agora.
Mas acho que não estou muito bem. Não.
Pegou uma, gripe rapaz.
Laringite ou faringite. Eu acho que é um desses dois.
Entendeu.
Aí. Eu tomei antibiótico hoje. O dia todo.
E vamos que vai.
Well that was being a chance to slow chegar. Enquanto isso, pessoal.
Você tirar alguma dúvida.
Fica à vontade.
E hoje eu vou querer exatamente começar tirando as dúvidas principais, porque hoje a gente vai, né?
Na verdade, concluir todo o processo de execução que a gente viu durante terça e quarta.
De aprender algumas coisas novas aqui. Mas eu quero.
Reforçar algumas coisas com vocês.
Obviamente que existem várias lacunas aí.
Durante a semana. Existem muitas coisas em aberto.
Mas se a gente olhar de longe, o que eu quero que vocês entendam.
é o Mindset e o processo de como abordar o problema. Então o problema ainda continua sendo o mesmo. Ele não mudou.
é só a forma como a gente aborda o problema, que é completamente diferente, que são cheias.
So cheios de nuances e de complicações. Então, o que a gente quer fazer na verdade, é aprender uma forma.
De olhar para os lugares certos e conseguir ser efetivo nesses lugares.
Então é isso que eu quero que vocês saiam.
Daqui, do Treinamento.
Porque o conteúdo está todo lá. A gente tem todas as apresentações, todas as melhores práticas. Camada ontológica.
Escrita. Task Spec. Sim, Wise converge.
é basicamente entrar nisso e navegar. E acho que o estudo começa. Não durante a semana. Ele começa depois do Boot Camp.
é vocês pegarem. Cara, quero entender tal coisa. Vai navegar. Pô, quero entender isso aqui.
Pô. Vou entender isso aqui. Agora. Pô como que o loop funciona.
Como que eu aplico nisso aqui, né? Olha o repositório como referência falo. Pô, eu quero fazer algo similar aqui. Como Que Eu Faria.
Nessas características. E aí vai estudando em relação a isso.
Eu acho que essa é a melhor forma de você tirar proveito. Por exemplo.
Eu fiz um treinamento de.
De engenharia genética no Meiven há uns dois meses atrás. Mais ou menos. E aí.
Eu vi algumas coisas que eu nunca tinha visto, como eram implementadas. Important. Mas eu gosto muito de não executar.
Eu gosto muito de prestar atenção e fazer anotação. Assim que eu estudo. Aí. Depois eu peguei o repositório, peguei os conteúdos.
E.
Infin.
Você não vai necessariamente utilizar o meu Framework. Ou talvez a minha forma de trabalhar.
Mas olhar para a forma que eu trabalho, que eu crio, as coisas.
E olhar para aquilo e falar. Pô beleza como que eu implemento no meu dia a dia no meu Workspace.
Eu acho que esse é o grande valor. Eu acho que no final do dia, acaba.
Que todo mundo vai ter, né?
Um framework. Cada um vai ter.
Vai ter uma forma de trabalhar com.
Com várias características, e chegar.
No final do dia, com o mesmo Result.
Agora, antes da gente começar, queria perguntar para vocês.
Primeiro, gostaria de perguntar qual é.
Qual foi o maior aprendizado até agora? A gente tem. Quantas pessoas eu quero vocês escreverem? A gente tem cinco pessoas.
é mais assim. Como machines.
Pode perguntar. Clóvis.
Que bom, cara.
Primeiro, parabéns, eu estou adorando aqui, camp.
Cara eu já? Passei.
No necesaramente
I'll put it that you desecuseo
Agenticento
Depending on the water is packing kids.
Repositore.
Mice
Entente valida, com don'tse compartilado.
Different.
Eu ja physi sola, essay contrato, e o comesso como BDR j'all encado compassanterio.
If we are a patch commandoce es porque.
um conveja.
With spec-driven development, a sus desico mito amplus.
Entomoce ten que des sentimento de las cos ectados de poden seiz ectadas con sus esco.
Might as well seno techno, a visible no que eliminatalia.
financiero qui…
un sentavo.
Muto mais.
Agora.
Au qui voce fallout.
Você já viu o que dá para fazer com isso? Então deixa eu te falar. O que dá pra fazer.
E o que eu faço lá nos clientes na piffian, tá, então eu já vou mostrar pra você exatamente a sua dor.
Então, o que acontece.
Você falou exatamente isso, porra! Eu tenho um ripo.
Vamos supor que.
Eu vou fazer ficar mais fácil, tá? Então vamos supor que eu tenho um ripo de front.
E eu tenho um ripo de Beck.
Set. Isso pode acontecer. Isso na verdade, acontece bastante.
E aí, se você pensar na vida real.
Na vida aqui do treinamento.
As coisas funcionam separadas na vida real. Elas funcionam juntos, né?
Então pode acontecer muitas das vezes.
Que o usuário. Nesse caso, você.
Que está desenvolvendo. Vai trabalhar com alguma coisa que possa tocar.
Esses dois repositórios.
E aí a sua pergunta é exatamente pô legal. Converge muito legal. Mas aí, teoricamente, eu teria em converge aqui.
Eu teria um converge aqui.
E aí eu faria o processo nos dois.
E depois eu transbordaria. Alguma coisa nos pô. Faz esse pedaço aqui. Então é meio que eu teria que fazer A Decomposição Um Pouquinho Antes Aqui.
Para entender o que eu mandaria de documento para cá. E o que eu mandaria de documento para lá, certo.
Beleza. Isso funciona, mas não é efetivo.
Como que a gente faz.
Então é exatamente o que você falou.
Você vai fazer exatamente isso aqui.
Que é o futuro das empresas, tá? Você já deve ter entendido.
Eu vou deixar simples. Vmcp, por exemplo.
Então imagina que ao invés de você ir nos repositórios, o que você quer na verdade, é.
Interagir.
Com uma interface.
Essa interface tem o contexto e a intenção dos seus repositórios ou dos grupos de repositório que você tem.
E na hora que você manda. Isso.
Ele vai destinar os planos e ele vai chamar o converge ali para poder fazer tudo isso.
Então você teria uma camada em relação a isso.
Quando você trabalha sozinho. Você trabalha num repositório.
Quando você vai trabalhar com uma equipe, o que você vai fazer? Você vai criar uma infraestrutura de Ia, e Você Vai Focar Ou Converge Lá Dentro.
Porque o converge. Vai conseguir fazer o quê?
Quando você falar com a intenção. E qual problema? E ele tiver com o texto, ele fala, Olha.
Essa mudança que você pediu aqui, ela afeta o front e o back.
Então eu vou passar o converge aqui e eu vou controlar tudo. E por que ele consegue controlar.
Porque ele tem a Swim Lenes. Ele tem as tarefas. Ele tem a queda. Então ele consegue fazer isso por repositório.
Então, o que a gente faz quando o cliente precisa de um a mais repositórios.
A gente coloca uma coisa na frente. Então converge a ponta para os dois repositórios, entendeu? E ele consegue ver Os Dois E Controlar Os Dois.
Pricing.
Essa. Aí é a pergunta de um milhão de dólares quem dominar isso é o profissional do futuro.
é sem dúvida alguma, porque o que está acontecendo agora, e isso já está acontecendo lá fora. E eu já Estou Falando Sobre Isso Prova é Que Eu Não Estou Mentindo.
Eu tive uma reunião essa semana com a Higienio.
Olha só. Eu passei duas horas com o cliente.
Falando de que, de contexto?
Porque o cliente, basicamente está falando, cara, olha, a gente tem dados de vários lugares. Eu queria saber como você Criar Uma Interface De Infraestrutura De Ar.
Aonde eu conseguisse passar por um processo de intenção e construir um software. Fim. Enfim, porque a gente tem vários repositórios e tal.
E eu comecei a desenhar com o cliente aqui.
Então isso já está acontecendo lá fora. Porque o que eles entenderam pô beleza.
Eu estou usando a Iak no meu contexto, no meu repositório. Mas em algum momento.
Eu preciso vários repositórios, vários contextosão. Vou ter que ter uma fonte, na verdade, ou algum local.
Aonde eu possa iniciar. E esse cara vai fazer o processo.
Por isso que tem muitas empresas, mas não são poucas, não implementando essa infraestrutura de ar, que é meio que Colocar Um Spec Dream Development Dentro Dele Colocar Um Converge Dentro Dele Que é Pô O Que Você Quer Construir Hoje.
Pô, eu preciso fazer isso. Isso pô, beleza.
No seu contexto. Isso toca os repositórios tais e tais. E tais. Você quer promover essa mudança? Pô, quero.
Deixa eu criar o requisito de problema pra você. é esse requisito, beleza.
Gerou requisito técnico. Esse é o requisito técnico. é beleza.
Quebrou os Edrs. Esses Edrs fazem sentido. Fazem.
Beleza. Deixa eu decompor. Faz sentido para você faz, tá? Agora pode deixar que eu vou executar daqui pra frente.
E ele sabe quais são os Poor Requests e os lugares que ele vai tocar e fazer, porque ele tem um contexto correto.
Então meio que essa camada teria que ser uma norma base graph de todos os repositórios e relacionamentos, e ela seria o acionador dos converges com, base nessa.
Isso, comece a simples. Faz assim. ó, vou te dar a V um Av. Um. é bem simples.
Só para você testar que aí você já vai achar muito foda isso. Porque quando eu fiz a primeira vez, Eu Achei Muito Legal.
Você vai fazer o seguinte dica de produto, tá que a gente tem aqui.
Vou mostrar pra você aqui, Github.
Ripo.
Então você vai basicamente fazer o seguinte.
Vou deixar simples, tá? Vou fazer a mesma ideia de frete. Vou de.
De front de back. E os caralho que eu estava mostrando aqui.
Então.
Eu tenho três repositórios no Git. Ah, mas o meu está no Ege Devops. Tanto faz. Tá.
Beleza. Eu tenho três repositórios. Qual a primeira coisa que você vai fazer.
Você vai criar.
Você vai criar um Layer de contexto.
Que vai basicamente fazer o seguinte.
Ele vai aqui.
Aqui.
Vai aqui.
E aí ele vai criar. Vamos botar como.
Eu desenhei aqui. Ele vai criar.
Estou te dando suco, tá?
Vamos, suquinha aí o nuggetezinho. Tomo Nuggetzinho.
Então, como que eu faço aqui? Eu pego Call Hippo Context.
Então, pá. Vai lá. Entende o repositório e traz. Qual é o contexto desse repositório?
Depois eu pego um outro agente inicial cara com a intenção desse reposório. Extrai as chaves principais, os jargões, as importâncias.
Você pode ver isso dentro do nosso repositório, que é na mesma pegada que isso. Aqui.
Você vier aqui no Day Four.
Norana.
No The.
No. Desculpa.
Docs.
Dentro de contexto.
Está vendo aqui?
Termos. Então, basicamente.
Fila. Isso aqui, beleza.
Então você tem esse contexto. Layer engine aqui. Então você tem essa ideia básica do que é.
Daí você bota o, converge.
Aqui o converge que você tem aí? Tá.
Vamos pegar para simplificar. Aqui pego, sei lá, Codex.
E você dentro do embrulho do Códex.
Fala para ele. Fala para o Converge. Apontar para essa camada de contexto, que é basicamente esses dois arquivos aqui.
E fala para ele o seguinte, cara, eu preciso fazer.
Uma modificação, por exemplo, que vai afetar os dois repositórios. Você vai ver que na verdade, ele vai conseguir te falar. Já.
Eu já desenhando pra te falar isso.
Então ele vai dar spec que vai estar em cada um desses ricos.
Por isso que eu tive que criar o Sim Wise.
Your Task Spec. Porque o que o senhor Ice vai fazer.
Ele vai decompor da forma correta. Só que não só para um repositório para múltiplos repositórios, sacou.
Alright angie.
Essa, parada de essa camada aí do, contex layer eu estava explorando estava fazendo com aquela biblioteca understanding assim os resultados.
Pô legal. Bom, gostou?
Interessante, agora é juntar os understanding todas para tentar, sair para esse cenário.
é isso. Mas isso aqui é simples de fazer teoricamente, para você testar.
A ponto. Converse. Fala, cara. Eu tenho um multitask.
é uma tarefa que envolve múltiplos repositórios, e eu gostaria desse contexto.
Eventualmente o que era fazendo? Converge.
é criar isso automático, né? é falar para ele o seguinte. Olha, esses são os repositórios que você vai olhar Para Esse Projeto E Ele Vai Fazer Isso Automaticamente Para A Gente.
Mas por enquanto, eu ainda não implementei isso, porque eu ainda estou testando isso.
Mas dá para você fazer.
Muito obrigado.
Beleza. Então escrevam aqui. Poucas pessoas escreveram gente.
Mário Botou o seguinte: achei muito boa a forma como os processos são quebrados, como automatizar isso com os Frameworks.
Eu falo isso todo dia para o meu time. E a companhia que jogou uma lupa nesse ponto.
é tipo cartão de tomar ajudado? Sim, exatamente.
Mas o que gente que vocês aprenderem.
Eu acho que um dos grandes pontos aqui do Boticamp é vocês literalmente entenderem a parte de decomposição, conseguir ver.
Uma tarefa nível atômica. Eu acho que essa é a parte pra mim.
Mais interessante de todas, porque ela mostra.
Que a gente consegue chegar no menor grão.
E esse menor grão é muito importante para a gente.
Muito, mesmo.
Me falem aí.
Inclusive deixou. Eu já apontar aqui.
Eu não sei quão atômica tarefa pode ser, mas eu tenho feito essa divisão em componentes. Funciona também.
Uma tarefa, uma.
Tarefa. E aí, por exemplo, às vezes, uma tarefa é muito grande.
Para ser uma tarefa só então talvez ela tenha que ser quebradas em múltiplas tarefas.
Daí ela. Na verdade, existe uma relação com uma outra tarefa de dependência.
Então, no Task Specing. Antigamente, eu só permitia até Medium Tasks.
Se fosse uma Big Task. Uma Xl ou uma L large task.
Na verdade, o que eu falava era para a gente voltar no problema e tentar decompor um pouquinho mais.
Mas aí eu fui trabalhando um pouquinho em Jane para poder fazer essa decomposição de forma mais efetiva. Pode perguntar.
Eu fiz essa, quebra em, componentes no sentido de.
Componentes, comporem, features que, compõem o projeto propriamente dito.
Só que eu tenho pego.
Tarefas.
Grandes.
E.
Eu também criei.
Relacionado a essas tarefas, e aos involus dela.
Contratos.
Que.
Com o propósito de que após esses componentes serem construídos.
Os contratos entrem, nos, evolz.
Também.
E.
Permitam que, um componente se comunique com o outro.
Permita ou não garantam.
Mas, eu ainda estou nesse, ponto de a tarefa é muito grande.
Aí.
Estou pensando ainda.
Aí? Sim, é o que eu fiz. Na verdade, foi dar o passo para trás. Eu tive esse mesmo problema Quando Eu Construí O Task Spec.
Por isso que eu construí isso em Wise.
Primeiro, eu fiz o Desk Spec. E daí? Eu comecei a lidar com o problema de uma tarefa muito grande.
E daí eu fiz exatamente o que eu passo para trás. Então falei: Pô se. A tarefa é muito grande, Então Basicamente é O Quê.
Só tem um problema aqui. A gente não decompôs ela. A gente não fez uma boa decomposição para quebrar ela menor.
Que uma tarefa grande sempre pode ser quebrada em tarefas menores, sempre.
Então por isso que eu criei o Sinuais.
Porque aí, antes de entrar no Task Spec, eu entro no. Sim Wise. E aí, se você olhar.
Dezassete, oitenta das tarefas que são executadas dentro do Test Spec. Na minha média.
De tarefas. Elas são entre pequenas e médias.
Cara. Dificilmente você vê uma tarefa grande, bem difícil, mas é muito difícil ver.
Por quê? Porque os cortes da decomposição já fazem isso. Então, o que eu faria no seu caso?
Passo para trás. Eu olharia uma forma como você quer quebrar.
Isso para chegar na sua decomposição com contrato enfim menor.
é o que eu faria.
Acho que é um bom caminho a seguir.
Recentemente eu tive que fazer um pipeline que.
A entrega é nenhum Upstream Nietzsche no Data Breaks. Tive que rodar dois Sdds.
No Agents Spec.
Agora quero outra demanda assim, para testar esse processo. Com essa nova visão em flebox. Beleza, gente. Então.
Vamos começar hoje o nosso quarto dia. A gente vai falar um pouquinho aqui sobre orquestração. Fechar alguns loops.
Inclusive falar de loop. Hoje.
E a gente vai entender. O componente principal.
Do converge.
Que é a parte de looping, uma vez que essas tarefas são definidas, que o processo é feito.
E que tudo está literalmente colocado no repositório.
A gente vai começar a interagir nisso, para que ele possa entrar num processo de execução mais autônomo.
E a gente vai entender amanhã, por exemplo, que o conceito de autônomo, diferentemente do que muita gente pensa.
Né? é.
Não está relacionado a se era autônomo ou se não era autônomo, está muito mais vinculado a um dial que você vai aumentando.
Então você pode ver. Por exemplo, no primeiro dia, a gente começou a pegada.
Muito mais cômodo. Muito mais assim, cara.
Esse é o grande escopo. Esse é o problema. No segundo dia, a gente começou a decompor.
No terceiro dia.
A gente decompôs também.
Pensando, no mínimo viável ali, no menor.
Grão no menor fio para poder fazer isso. Esse é Steel Threat.
E aí isso por que a gente queria assistiu Treads.
é uma forma de você validar o seu processo. é uma forma de você garantir.
Que o seu processo vai funcionar em grande escala ou de forma repetitiva.
Então é como se você estivesse fazendo literalmente um teste inicial do seu sistema.
Como se você estivesse rodando ele a primeira vez, e você estivesse testando ele de fato.
Então é para isso? Basicamente.
Que a gente tem o processo. Tá?
E aí, o que a gente quer ver hoje, né?
A gente quer ver isso com a perspectiva do que eu chamo de um Ai Native Engineer.
A gente vestiu várias, vários hats esses dias. E esse dia eu quero vestir o hatch que eu acredito que vocês devem.
De fato vestir, né?
Porque a gente ainda não fechou os processos, mas tem algumas coisas importantes.
Todos os códigos novos para a nova plataforma que a gente está criando. Ela está dentro da pasta de Modern.
Então, se a gente for lá agora, inclusive a gente tem essas informações. Já lá.
A gente tem toda a parte de ingestão de dado que está guardada dentro dele.
Inclusive. Olha que legal! Que aconteceu aqui agora aconteceu uma coisa muito legal. Agora.
Deixa eu ver. Uma coisa melhor aconteceu aqui.
Tipo deu merda. Basicamente.
Eu só tô vendo.
As execuções que aconteceram antes de ontem.
Ontem. Na verdade, não. As de ontem.
Só um minutinho.
é como se o trabalho de ontem não estivesse aparecendo aqui.
Ou ele foi sobre escrito de alguma forma.
Não tem problema que a gente pode gerar tudo porque a gente tem os skates. Eu vou colocar aqui para gerar.
Mas.
Me dá um minutinho para eu colocar isso aqui pra rodar.
Que, por algum motivo.
O. Perdi. Isso aqui.
Então deixa eu só voltar. Me dá um minutinho aqui, Rapidão. Só inicializar.
Beleza. Vou deixar executar aqui e a gente vai.
Então, o que a gente vai ver, né? A gente tem a parte moderna de Landing que a gente criou, Que Foi A Primeira Parte Da Engenharia De Software Na Segunda Parte A Gente Fez.
O design do Lake House com Dlt.
E com Duck Lake e o Duck. Db: E a gente teve uma terceiro perna, que era o Dbt.
Para poder ir por cima disso e criar nossas camadas bronze, seu brigode.
Com isso. Quando a gente executa isso dentro, tá.
O que a gente tem. A gente tem uma evidência. Então, dentro, lá da pasta de evidência, quando a gente rodar, esse cara.
A gente. Convivência para saber o quê?
Se de fato, essa execução bate o contrato.
Lembra. Então a gente quer garantir que esse contrato, ele está batendo ou não.
Com o Golden Match. é isso que a gente quer saber.
Se ele funcionou ou não funcionou.
Então eu vou mostrar para vocês um pouquinho aqui.
Então, basicamente, qual é a ideia da evidência.
A gente executa um Bet no legado.
E a gente bate lá. O número correto.
A gente executa esse mesmo, Bet.
No moderno. E a gente quer garantir se ele deu certo ou não.
Essa é a forma da gente garantir que o que a gente implementou.
Está completamente correto ou não? Tá?
A gente vai ver, por exemplo, que existem alguns Birds que vieram com erro lá no trailer. Lembra lá na Soma Quando A Gente, Tem Um Detalhe.
Daquela junção da soma. O valor. Ele tem que bater.
Se existe uma discrepância, a gente não pode.
Excluir a gente. Tem que simplesmente fregar essa informação.
E a gente já vê que todas as informações que a gente criou. Elas estão lá no Task. Era para Elas Estarem Aqui Dentro Dos Docs.
Porque, por exemplo, se a gente olhar agora, o último pro Request que eu fiz há cinco minutos atrás.
Se a gente vier aqui em Docs.
Se a gente vê em Tasks.
Eu não tenho nada. Basicamente.
Ele basicamente excluiu toda a execução que a gente fez aqui só ficou esse thread inicial.
Mas eu estou pedindo aqui para executar.
O dia três para refazer o dia três inteiro.
Então demora ali uns, sei lá, uns dez minutos. Quinze minutos para a gente refazer o dia.
No dia três, espero. Mas a gente vai conversando aqui por enquanto.
Bem o que a gente tem de documento. A gente tem um documento de consenso.
Que ele ainda está lá dentro. A gente tem um documento de Sims.
Do que foi cortado. E esses dois documentos são os documentos que mostram pra gente o que a gente acordou.
E quais são as divisões dos sistemas? Quais são as dobras e cortes do sistema.
Se a gente olhar aqui.
Vamos dar uma olhadinha nesse cara.
Doing here.
A gente está olhando somente a parte do Type. Um do Landing. Porque não foi atualizado em.
Ainda. Mas o que ele cortou? Como ele cortou isso.
Ele cortou esse cara.
Um nível.
De ingest lending.
Um outro nível de Dlt e Gold.
Outro de orquestate serve.
Então, basicamente, como ele cortou o sistema.
Foi um pouco diferente do que eu, por exemplo, cortaria.
Eu cortaria. Talvez.
De uma forma bronze sever ou algo desse tipo. Mas se a gente pensar um pouquinho nessas cortes aqui.
Eles fazem mais sentidos, tá? Por quê?
Quando a gente fala de Ingest Landing. Olha só o Sim.
é fazer o quê? é pegar o tipo um.
Do dado cru ao dado sanitizado.
Quem consome essas informações?
Quem produz essas informações com a surface de escrita.
O que você deve fazer e o que não. Então o que a Leg faz, né?
O que o sim faz. Ele entende todas essas relações. Pô. Então não é só separar.
Python. Eu preciso saber o seguinte. Pô.
Aonde o sistema cortado existe uma dependência de Sftp.
Position a dependência de conversão, de aplicação.
Existe uma dependência de modelo.
Então, o que ele vai optar a fazer? Ele vai optar a criar um Sim.
Muito maior para que ele possa ter a Swim Lenes mais bem definidas.
Então é a mesma coisa aqui. Ele vai sempre olhar isso de forma automática, tá? E aí, se vocês quiserem entender a regra.
Que ele faz isso aí? Vocês vão no convergem.
Aqui dentro de converge e a gente pode. A gente tem um converge aqui, né?
Mostra o Troubleshooting Luan. Mostro basicamente, eu falei pra ele o seguinte: eu citei um objetivo. Boa pergunta.
Aqui. ó.
Basicamente, você tem um objetivo.
Eu falei para ele. Olha, nós perdemos o dia inteiro que está no D. Tres.
Não tem nada. Basicamente, no Modern, que é o local.
Aonde ele faz. E eu. Eu botei um objetivo que a gente já falou hoje. O objetivo.
Deve executar de fim a fim.
Para que o próximo.
Espaço seja completo. Então, o que ele vai fazer.
Ele vai entrar dentro do Run D tres. E ele vai basicamente executar todo esse processo.
Para criar nossa trilha moderna. Então ele já começou.
A fazer todo o processo.
Então que ele citou os objetivos. Emitir.
Colocar fazer alteração no disco. Então a gente já tem as alterações aqui acontecendo, sendo criadas.
E essa é uma alteração que eu queria saber exatamente o simples como ele vai cortar essas informações. Tá vendo?
Obrigado por perguntar pelo debugging. Que essa é a parte legal. Realmente tá.
Então, se a gente voltar aqui. ó.
Que que o Senhoras faz, né? Ele é feito para cortar as iniciativas em distintos honestiques.
Chamado de Swimane. Esse processo garante que.
Softwares complexos podem servir compostos de uma arquitetura e limites naturais.
Antes de qualquer implementação em sistemas distribuídos. Tá.
Então, para a sua pergunta, ele já foi desenhado para multi, para multisistemas. Então.
Em padrões, em padrões.
Em sistemas. Padrões, como no affilmente pay, né?
O arquitetura natural segue o processo seguinte. Ingestão.
Sanitização, Privacidade.
Staging posting, reconciliação.
Então, para construir.
Mapa. Enforçar os swimlandes. Os finais. Executa um processo rígido passo a passo de um pipeline.
Então, olha, são muito legal. Primeiro.
Ele vai desenvolver.
Tá? O desenvolvimento de Workspace é preparado.
Podem. Inicialização da estrutura.
Ele vai dar um In It. O que acontece é que ele está mostrando os pedaços, né?
Ele vai projetar e desenhar. Vai criar o que ele chama de Seeingwise. Recipe.
Vai verificar quais são as iniciativas, quais são as informações que ele tem? Vai verificar os Ads.
E ele vai executar um sim. Wise Map.
Uma vez que essa receita é programada, uma Clay vai validar essa receita contra o repositório.
Para construir uma dependência de topologia.
Ler essa receita e checa contra o layout do repositório para entender os planos.
E aí ele cria um plano. Sim, Wise plane.
Com a estrutura mapeada resolvida, ele gera um draft.
Particionado.
E aí ele vê se ele precisa review ou não. E daí? Ele tem um consentimento humano ou não sobre isso.
Ele gera a compilação, que é basicamente dizer para ele qual o plano que ele vai gerar. Ele gera um plano.
Cortando entre os sistemas.
Pode perguntar, Flávio. Deixa, eu.
Vontade de ser. Fica à vontade.
Ô luan quando você cria os contratos é nessa parte que você entrega integra com o linear.
Para, ele subir as, atividades.
Não vai ser depois vai ser daqui a vai ser um pouquinho pra frente.
São dois passos depois aqui.
Tá bom, tá bom.
Então aqui eu cortei.
Dois. Vamos verificar como que a gente está aqui.
Já foi.
Já chegou a ter saturação de Mds para gerencial ficar ruim de gerenciar.
Lucas. Sim, aqui.
Esse projeto é gigantesco. Tá.
Só para você ter uma ideia do tamanho desse projeto.
Vou dar. Vou dar aqui uma noção.
Desse arquivo que eu construí hoje, tá? Ele tem cento e tantas páginas, que é o que eu vou ler Quando Eu Estiver Viajando Amanhã.
Com as atualizações do que a fábrica fez, e assim por diante.
Então quando você tem saturação, o que você vai usar, né?
Você vai usar o Ufk.
Então, o Fq. O que ele vai fazer é um padrão da Google.
Que é o open knowledge format. Você vai falar, cara. Eu quero implementar o Ufk.
Dentro do meu repositório. Então, o que ele faz basicamente, né?
Ele cria.
Essa pasta de knowledge.
E daí, com essas informações, ele cria um índice.
Um log do que foi gerado toda vez.
E daí? Ele vai organizando toda a documentação do seu sistema aqui, e ele aponta isso lá no Agentesmd.
Então, olha só. Que legal. Por exemplo, componentes eu tenho Flowcheck.
Flowcheck. é o in China que eu.
Criei para poder fazer todo tipo de validação que existe dentro do sistema.
Então, o que isso aqui é? Fod.
Porque o agente é apontado para o knowledge. Aí ele falou: Opa, Beleza. Quero saber sobre o Flowcheck.
Então ele vai lá. Entra aqui.
E aí ele sabe. Aqui, olha só. Que foda.
Resource Hippocurv de Pcrcc cli. Então ele vem.
Essa. Cc cli.
E aí ele tem o flow check.
Tá vendo? Faz um index.
Então, cara, todo projeto que é grande, você sempre vai implementar.
Ou Fk: Isso aqui funciona para ambientes com dez, vinte, trinta zero de linhas de código.
Então, foda de vocês implementarem.
é ajuda bastante. ó.
Um excelente exemplo de como decompor o nosso wind Pay.
é focar no tipo de card settlement.
Esse streaming é perfeito para decombustão, porque ele tem legado de cobol.
Privacidade e tem que ser feito. O quê? Tem que fazer um passe.
Overpunch. Complexo.
E tem ainda um intencional fonte da mentira.
E tem que ser controlado por uma recusa de Beth.
Utilizando se um Wise, o sistema vai ser dividido.
A gente vai basicamente quebrar isso.
Utilizando os limites físicos naturais dos Sims em limpos, independentes e verificáveis. Então é isso que eu quero que vocês entendam.
O Cinns. Eles são desenvolvidos e cortados de forma limpa.
Independentes e verificáveis. Alguém perguntou aqui e agora? Eu lembrei.
Alô. Era uma tarefa. Fica muito grande. Quando o Task Spec quebra, existe a dependência e whatnot.
Então, boa pergunta. O que acontece? Tá.
Quando uma tarefa é criada.
Uma lag da tarefa criada. O Task Spec sabe exatamente qual a dependência de uma tarefa com outra.
Então, por exemplo, se a gente vier aqui em Docs.
Desks. Deixa eu pegar aqui, por exemplo.
Essa Task.
Eu queria mostrar.
Como a gente está querendo separ.
Acho que ele não tem aqui. Tá, mas, por exemplo.
Quando houver.
Uma tarefa que depende de outra.
Ela vai ser. Ela vai ser mostrada assim.
Desse jeito. Então existe uma dependência de uma tarefa com a outra.
Aonde essa Tf. Gold depende do Tf. Publish.
Então, se eu clicar na Tf Gold, aqui.
Onde eu clico aqui. Cadê a relação?
Aqui, ó. Bloqueada pela Tf Gold.
Então eu tenho a referência aqui.
Dessa tarefa, dessa atividade. O que é que ela é.
Posso até abrir depois aqui no cerveja local. Enfim, ele contava para o.
I'm afraid change my bank.
Mas você viu aqui que a gente tem a referência, né?
Que a gente consegue.
Bush gold as duck, Db.
The clique. Mas existe uma dependência entre esses dois aqui. Então.
Ele vai mostrar o bloqueio dessas atividades.
Deixa eu ver se tem uma outra. Mais rádio aqui.
Eu tinha alguma. Não estou tragédia. Não tem.
Aqui. ó.
Aqui, ó relacionada. Tá vendo?
As tarefas que têm relacionadas. Tá vendo? ó, por exemplo, a camada de.
Serve. Tá vendo aqui?
Eu não posso criar camada de servem sem criar.
Primeiro. A minha camada básica de entrada do service do serve.
Então, basicamente, existe uma referência. Por exemplo, transforma.
Eu preciso publicar para depois fazer o Transform. Então toda essa referência de atividade.
Ela mostra aqui tá? Toda ela.
Deixa eu só voltar aqui. Então, ó.
Primeiro, o recipe que a gente perguntou, ele vai colocar o seguinte.
Scene seem robites seeing privacy seem integration see staging.
Swim Lanes Lane Parse.
Legs Playing Privacy.
Legs. Lena Validation.
Legs Lane Station.
Olha que legal. Depois o comando faz o quê? Ele vai fazer um workspace niche.
Depois ele ia fazer um mapping do repositório para ver se Beat.
Depois ele ia fazer um draft.
Para verificar as despesas de Review ou não.
Eu posso autorizar isso ou não. Ele pode ser automático. Tá.
E daí? Ele vai gerar uma Deg. E vai criar essas paradas inteiras para mim. Muito foda, né?
Eu adoro isso aqui. Então, assim.
Pesquise sobre.
Inclusive isso aqui é usado.
Dentro disso. Aqui, ó.
Deixa eu ver se é mesmo.
Para quem não conhece esse Plugin. é só o Plugin. Muito usado, tá? Tem duzentos e setenta e nove mil.
Downloads, que é o super Powers. Basicamente, você instala ele e você ganha superpoderes.
Você consegue fazer uma cacetada de coisas aqui.
Ele tem.
Brainstorming. Escrita de plano, execução de plano. Olha lá. Mesma coisa. Tá vendo?
Brainstorming. Escreve planos e culta. O plano faz o. Despachem de agentes paralelos.
Is yet code review.
Recebe, trabalha Cook Trees. Tá.
Então assim ele tem tudo. E você vai trabalhando manual ali que nem o match Pok, né? Na mesma ideia.
Você vai fazendo isso, cara. E esse cara é muito, muito, muito usado, tá? Muitos devs que eu conheço utilizam.
Então, se a gente vier aqui perguntar.
Vamos ver.
Why tá aqui, meu amor.
Você está aqui?
Não agora foi, eu acho. Olha lá. Assim o Super Power. Ele usa algo similar na sua filosofia de código De Composição E Tarefa De Coração.
Mas aplica.
Mas aplica essa metodologia numa altitude diferente de arquitetura. Ambos os sistemas são desenhados para eliminar.
O Higentec Eslopp.
Prevenir. Llms from Going off Track.
Or going sideways or derail. A mesma coisa. Sair do que realmente a intenção seria.
Mas ele faz de formas complementares. Tá vendo? Então aqui ele explica um pouquinho.
Então, por exemplo, o Sinwise.
O primeiro nível de decomposição dele é nível arquitetural.
Nu superpowers. Ele faz isso no nível de tarefa.
Aqui como que a gente faz o forcing disso, né?
A gente faz por portões criptográficos. A gente faz isso por uma cli.
Com Seals H. Mac.
Porque se alguém tentar fazer a leitura disso.
Que não esteja no meu processo. Tentar fazer.
Uma Injection. Alguma coisa. Eu quebro esse contrato e tem um tempering disso. Então eu simplesmente descarto.
Esse cara aqui vai por nível Prompt.
Aqui. A gente tem um nível de execução que no final do Sinwise, vai gerar um plano de hand off Para O Task Spec.
Aqui. Ele vai chamar um Sub agent de Spectrum Development para Lupar e fazer.
Então e Ultimately Wise and Architecture System Splitter.
Então ele é um nível arquitetural de splitter. Para estabelecer alto nível de mapeamento do mais alto para o menor.
I'll just be Powers. é um Companion de.
Procedural de engenharia. Mas no final do dia.
It is idea mesmo é de comport.
Legal.
Acharam interess.
E a gente tem aqui.
Também o nosso contrato, né?
Nosso contrato que a gente recebeu do Solutions Architect, que a gente vai entrar um pouquinho mais em detalhe hoje.
E aí, gente? O que eu acredito que hoje nós oitenta.
Noventa e dois pessoas que estão aqui irão se tornar inevitavelmente.
E muita gente.
Que navegar mais rápido.
Vai conseguir chegar a alguns pontos mais rápidos e, obviamente, vai conseguir ver de uma forma muito mais clara.
Então eu lembro quando eu e o Rafael, a gente começou a discutir sobre.
Sistemas agênticos com as experiências nossas. Enfim.
Que a gente estava discutindo muita coisa cara que a gente começou a escutar. Agora.
Aqui. Ah, mas pô. Isso quer dizer o quê? Isso quer dizer que a gente.
Estava mais na frente, porque a gente estava lidando já com o problema, né?
Então, pô. Quando eu criei o Agents Spec, ninguém fazia Spectre vender. Poucas pessoas faziam spectro, principalmente na área de dados.
Aí. Pô vai contexto. Eu estou falando para vocês. Pô contexto é algo extremamente importante. Enfim.
A gente ainda injeta as coisas no chat. Eu pego uma coisa ali. Boto um Second de Brain injeta contexto.
Since. Daqui a pouco vão ver cara com texto nível: Enterprise.
E seja bom ter escutado isso.
Vocês vão ver se tem muita gente. Depois tem decomposição.
Então vocês estão na frente. Isso coloca a cabeça de vocês num ponto.
Bem interessante de discutir, de se destacar na empresa.
De trazer novas formas de como resolver o problema. Então essa é a grande ideia.
Bem.
A grande ideia é eventualmente.
Para um processo que é contínuo.
E aí, quando eu falo contínuo, o que eu estou falando?
Eu estou falando que esse processo, ele não é uma vez só.
Ele vai acontecer durante várias vezes.
Deixa eu só botar meus agentes para cozinhar aqui, que eu estourei a minha assinatura. Ela acabou de voltar.
Do que me vai que continua.
Brilha.
Então, assim a grande ideia aqui é criar algo que você possa deixar.
De uma forma.
Pouco mais autônomo ou totalmente autônomo. O que vai definir é basicamente.
O quão você consegue implementar.
Os Portões.
Para que você possa sair do loop.
Uma das coisas que eu recomendo demais. Quando você está indo para um sistema agêntico.
E você está delegando tarefa para ele.
é você ter uma forma de verificar o trabalho dele.
De forma humana. Por isso eu recomendo Linear.
Existem vários. Eu gosto de vários.
Mas eu acho que o linear, de longe é o melhor para controlar.
Principalmente dos sistemas agênticos.
E a questão do porquê você consegue controlar.
é porque a forma com que ele.
Entrega. E como ele integra.
é muito fácil, tá? Então você tem ali um backlog. Você tem Mcps? Você tem triagem.
E o agente entende isso. Então ele consegue trabalhar com tudo isso.
Ele também tem um sistema genético dentro dele.
Em que você também consegue trabalhar. Então assim, cara, é um cara muito legal para você.
Fazer o gerenciamento de Workflows dentro dele.
Luan. Eu posso fazer isso em outro lugar. Pode? Tem Githubishios. Tem Git Lab.
Tem Azure, Azure. Enfim.
Tasks e assim por gente, tá, então.
Só tem um board para controlar. é importante.
Não deixa isso só no repositório.
Porque você não tem um app? Você não tem nada muito visível nisso.
E o que é legal é que.
Se você deixa isso no líder.
Você consegue saber todos os passos que a gente executou?
Então, por exemplo.
So pegar aqui!
A gente vai fazer isso hoje, tá?
Aqui. ó, aqui é uma extra small, né.
E aí? Olha só.
Eu consigo saber que cara a Indign, que foi concebida pra ele foi o Codex.
O Spec foi esse. Deixa eu pegar o mais atual.
Deixa eu pegar aqui, por exemplo.
Sim, Wise.
Deixa eu ver se eu tenho atividade no Task Spec. Ele já limpou todas.
Aqui.
Então, o que ele faz? Olha só. Que legal.
Você tem todas as informações aqui.
Você tem as atividades. E você tem aqui os Resources de referência. Então você pode apontar ele para o Git. Ele Tem Toda A Documentação.
E caso você queira, você pode também utilizar o agente dele para perguntar as coisas sobre a tarefa que ele Já Está No Conceito.
Já está num.
Ele já está no contexto.
Então você pede para ele te explicar a tarefa. Ele pode te explicar. Então o que eu adoro aqui.
Você está em qualquer lugar.
E aí o seu agente está trabalhando em vários repositórios, escrevendo ali nos seus negócios.
E você está ali, interagindo com as tarefas e entendendo o que está acontecendo.
Então eu gosto muito de utilizar ele para isso.
Outra coisa.
Para que você possa sair e implementar os Gates. Você precisa.
Entender o conceito de volta. Precisa entender e aplicar. Evol no seu dia a dia.
Então, para vocês terem ideia o quanto em vol é importante.
Deixa eu mostrar para vocês.
Quatro mil e duzentos, no treinamento de voz.
Só de valsa.
Quatro mil e duzentos não é de reais. São dólares.
Tá.
Outro. Se a gente pegar aqui.
A gente tem dinheiro. Boot Camp para Engineers. E ai Pms. Tá vendo ai? Pms.
Se você pegar aqui, ó, a gente que é engineering que nem existia. Dois a três, quatro meses atrás, cinco Meses Atrás Olha Só.
Esse aqui é bem famos.
Dois mil e quinhentos dólares.
O que ele fala aqui dentro.
Então, como subir uma frota de muita gente?
Como fazer engenharia de contexto.
Como mover contextos entre vários.
é.
Entre vários Llms.
Como escrever output estruturado.
Como desenhar voz.
Como arquitetar sistemas multiagênicos.
E como rodar sistemas vinte e quatro x sete.
Então essa disciplina.
Vem cada vez mais crescendo abruptamente. Então.
Porque eu estou mostrando e ensinando para vocês aqui não é algo da minha cabeça.
é algo realmente.
Em que está explodindo lá fora. E aí, se você olhar os conceitos aqui.
é basicamente muitas coisas que vocês estão estudando aqui. é a mesma coisa. Tá.
Vai usar conceitos diferentes. Por exemplo, o cara vai usar ling graph. Enfim.
Mas no final das coisas, no final do frigio dos ovos, vai ser o mesmo conceito.
Eu realmente focaria.
Em aprender os conceitos disso, porque as ferramentas vão ser só o final desse processo.
Então deixaria muito mais fácil para você aprender e literalmente saber quais são os pedaços que você vai aplicar.
E escolher. Mas aqui é um lugar legal de treinamento. O Meiiven é um dos lugares ultimamente que eu tenho.
Eu tenho um namorado bastante. Eu já fiz um treinamento aqui. Gostei.
E eu gosto muito do modelo do Maiven. Tá?
Então muitas das inspirações de treinamento que eu trago para vocês vem daqui.
Você precisa entenderem fontes de criação. Vende aqui vem do Youtube. Vem de algumas pessoas que eu acho muito legal.
Então eu faço um misto de coisa, tá.
Como disputa com os indianos e chineses. Os professores são sempre desses dois países.
Eles são cinco anos na frente. Sem pré. Os caras estão na frente. Realmente.
Indiscutivelmente tá.
Beleza.
Então eu quero que vocês entendam.
Que tudo começa aqui.
E eu acho que eu estressei bastante isso ontem.
Eu quero deixar claro aqui só um pouquinho desse ecossistema como um todo.
Context is king.
Harness is the Mount.
Então quero que vocês.
Lembrem disso.
O que aconteceu aqui? Meu Deus!
Por que o contexto é chave.
Né.
Não acredito que não vai seguir.
Por que o contexto é chave aqui tá.
Porque é onde estão todas as suas informações. E em algum momento, essas informações precisam ser classificadas.
Elas precisam ser melhoradas. Então você vai encontrar informações no setor de Brem.
Você vai encontrar informações em camada odontológica. Você vai encontrar informações em tipos de documentos separados na empresa.
E daí a gente vai aumentando essa superfície.
Você vai começar a achar. Por exemplo, conversas no Slack.
Você vai começar a achar transcripts.
E assim por diante. E aí a gente vale e continua. E continua.
Então o começo.
Para a sua empresa.
Em algum momento, apostar muito fortemente numa camada de contexto.
Então, eventualmente, a gente vai começar a perceber que isso aqui é uma das coisas mais importantes.
Que tem e obviamente que.
Cada vez mais, a gente vai se tirando desses loops e desses anéis que eu vou mostrar.
E esse anel aqui? Eu acredito que ele não vai ser automatizado. Anytime Soon nem perto, tá? Por quê?
Porque ele precisa de julgamento.
Então, quando a gente olha e vol hoje e volta explodido. Por quê? Carival é o local onde realmente eu preciso sentar.
E passar tempo para garantir que tudo que foi feito ali no sistema gêntico, tudo que foi desenhado, ele realmente bate.
Por exemplo, se a gente for olhar no conceito.
Básico do que a gente viu. Até.
Se eu pego uma tarefa.
Olha só a instrução.
A instrução para eu construir alguma coisa.
Weival deve passar então na tarefa.
Eu escrevi. Olha só.
Eu escrevi a intenção.
Reconstruir a Gold. O Ival.
Executar um script. Golden Match Pi.
Combate cento e quarenta e dois.
E ela ainda não foi assinalada para ninguém. Tá vendo.
False.
Isso. Aqui está escrito.
Ele não está verificado.
E daí? O que acontece.
Quando esse Ivol.
Ele vai ser executado.
Então eu tenho o quê? O Golden Match. Para executar esse cara.
Verificar se o Bet cento e quarenta e dois.
Ele bate com o valor.
E aí, quando esse cara bate.
Você tem que ter. O quê? O julgamento.
De alguma coisa que diz o que é certo.
No nosso sistema. A gente tem o que diz que é certo.
Que é a nossa evidência.
Mas, e muitas vezes, a evidência é quem o humano.
Você evidencia.
Você que tem que estar lá.
E literalmente, entender.
O que está sendo feito.
E o que vai ser colocado ou não.
Deu para entender. Então, na prática, eu tenho um Task Spec. Gerei um Invol e volta lá.
Executei. Tá.
Executei. Ah, boa boa pergunta.
Bugay no Never Runs.
O que significa never runs? Isso aqui é uma ótima pergunta, gente. Vocês têm que tirar dúvidas. Vocês estão aqui para isso.
Então, olha só. Se a gente vê aqui.
Docs Tasks. Vamos pegar uma tarefa aqui.
Tá, então.
O Task Spec escreveu esse voo.
Mas como?
Se você vê, ele está como Signage off.
Isso não quer dizer que isso foi executado.
Então ele escreve.
O evolque tem que ser feita.
Mas ele não executa o Evol, que tem que ser feito.
Então quando esse Vol.
Ele é executado por uma que vai pegar essa tarefa. Pô, eu vou executar essa tarefa.
A gente consegue ver no Estado, por exemplo.
Que eu tenho tarefas.
Eu tenho os status.
E eu tenho que estar naquilo.
O que está em progresso e o que está bloqueado. Então, quando uma tarefa já foi executada aqui.
Ela é pega.
Eu tenho a informação interna.
Aqui. ó, deixa abrir.
Que ela foi executada e assinalada por alguém.
Então, por exemplo, se a gente pegar esse vol aqui, Type Silver, deixa eu pegar um vol de.
Esse é um voyage do Dbte. Deixa eu ver.
Olha aqui. Olha só. Que legal.
Esse Vol vai fazer um teste. Vai fazer um grap no Purchase para ver se tem Purchase.
Vai fazer um grap. Aqui, tá.
Então aqui ele está só verificando se existe.
Alguma dessas palavras aqui dentro?
Desse script.
Tá.
Aqui. Ele está retornando um teste e fazendo grepe.
Então isso aqui não é um Evol forte.
O inval forte seria cara.
Executa para mim um Dbt run. Alguma coisa inclusive tem alguns que tem.
Não sei porque ele não construiu o Dbt. Cadê.
Deixa eu ver se eu acho um.
O Asset já é um pouco melhor.
Ele vai testar um código. Vamos ver o que mais ele tem que ele escreveu.
E aí existem níveis. Tá dentro do Task Spec. A gente escreve níveis.
Aqui. Eu deixo o nível mais simples de voz.
Mas a gente pode. A gente tem três níveis de voos aqui.
Mas a ideia que você pode falar. Quais são os involves que você quer? Pô, eu quero.
Para essa tarefa. Eu tenho uma tarefa. Por exemplo, de bronze. Pô, eu quero validar isso. Isso e isso.
Aqui. ó.
Que ele não executou ainda.
Só está dando Grep.
Então, por exemplo.
Um exemplo. Um Ival pode dar verde.
Mas pode não estar correto. Concorda comigo? Porque o que acontece aqui.
Bom supor que eu preciso criar aqui um Sql.
Que tenha, por exemplo.
Um decimal de dezoito e doze.
Beleza. Eu verifiquei aqui. Dezoito e doze.
Vai dar verde. Eu tenho lá um decimal declarado dezoito e doze.
Mas será que esse cara tá na coluna certa.
Será que o decimal.
Realmente. Dezoito, doze.
Era pra estar dentro do Saucie Record Number, por exemplo.
Então ele vai dar como certo, mas isso não quer dizer que está correto. Ele vai assinalar que passou o cheque.
Mas isso não quer dizer que está correto. Então aqui eu tenho Val. Somente para validar.
Em geral, o que eu quero. Mas a ideia é que a gente consiga.
Literalmente especificar o que a gente quer em grande escala.
Tá.
E aí, por exemplo, quando a gente olha esse processo, como que é uma forma de você.
Entender o loop dele, né.
Então, quando a gente rodou lá no primeiro dia, o Make Run, que cria um arquivo de reconciliação.
Essa aqui é o quê? A nossa prova do que já está em disco. Então, o que de fato.
A evidência vai provar, né?
Ela vai confirmar se.
O Ival Bacci. Isso é classificação aqui. ó, existe.
Seis tipos de classificação desse ball.
Eu tenho um defeito na fonte.
Eu tenho um defeito de legado.
Eu tenho um defeito no moderno.
Eu tenho uma ambiguidade.
Tem uma mudança aprovada ou tenho algo que não foi resolvido. Então, basicamente, ele vai.
Falar. Confirmed source defect.
Então eu tenho um problema na fonte.
Por quê? Porque, na verdade, o que a gente falou, né? O valor vem errado. Isso não quer dizer que A Gente Precisa Consertar Esse Cara.
Beleza. Uma forma de você rastrear muito isso é você ter um sistema.
Como línea, para poder rastrear todas essas informações aqui.
Por quê? Porque quando a gente entra aqui dentro.
Desse processo como um todo.
Que. Que a gente está começando a ver.
Que cada pedaço desse tenha uma especificidade. E a gente já começou a analisar cada uma delas em detalhe.
Perguntas na vida real, num projeto com muitas tarefas. Complexo de gerenciar, acompanhar a fábrica.
ótima pergunta. é.
Inclusive tem coisa que foi executada hoje, que eu não sei.
Então, por exemplo, tem coisas que estão na Queue para serem executadas hoje, inclusive.
Vinte, que ainda não foi executada.
Tá vendo?
Então eu tenho tarefas, ainda que não foram executadas aqui, que devem ser executadas.
Que ele está quebrando. Font.
Mas está aqui. ó.
Uma tarefa. Ela que aí ela é uma tarefa larde. Por exemplo.
Então tem aqui as Archives, os planos que foram gerados e assim por diante. Então.
Sim, Tiago é complexo.
E daí você começa a entender o seguinte: pô, imagina que eu tenho uma fábrica ou um projeto rodando aqui.
Agora imagino que eu tenho seis desses.
Pô. Eu vou todo dia entrar nesse local e fazer isso. Não, você vai ter que criar uma camada de Abstração Em Cima Disso Né.
Então pensa comigo o seguinte: como eu imagino nós.
Ai, Engineers. Sendo produtivos.
Então vou falar um pouco da minha experiência, tá? Hoje eu tenho.
O Task Spec.
Eu falar de alguns projetos que eu toco, tá?
Sim, Wise.
Eu tenho o. Converge.
Aí. Eu tenho.
Outros projetos.
E aí, obviamente que muitos deles precisavam do que de Hand Holding, né? Eu tenho que ficar olhando.
Entro, vejo, volto e tal aí tempo. Vou tirar esses três, porque aí senão fica aquela parada. Tipo assim. Ah, Você Tá Usando O Mesmo Projeto Mas Vou Pegar Aqui Por Exemplo.
We agent contextual que eu mostrei para vocês. é um projeto que eu estou ativamente trabalhando.
Tá, então ele é um projeto.
Eu vou falar para vocês. Por que eu estou desenhando isso aqui? Tá.
Depois outro projeto que eu toco.
Onix. é um outro projeto que eu toco.
Então o meu projeto de Seconds, Brain.
E eu vou pegar um outro projeto que eu toco. Também.
Que eu constantemente.
Trabalho, que é o Semates.
E aí vou pegar outro projeto. Agora que eu toco, curve.
E aí vou pegar outro projeto que eu toco.
Agora eu vou começar a trabalhar. No qual o nome N Contracts.
Tá vendo tanto de projeto.
E aí o seguinte: como que você trabalha em tanto projeto.
Entregando coisa. Foda.
Você tem que criar uma forma.
Um framework de abstração. Você tem que fazer alguma coisa.
Ou você vai ficar que nem eu já fiz de um lado pro outro feito. Um louco, né? Pra cá, Pra Cá Pra Cá Pra Cá Pra Cá Pra Cá.
E a cabeça simplesmente fica doida.
Então, qual é a grande ideia aqui, né? A grande ideia. Você tem.
Um barramento de Simwise. Mais Task Spec.
Nesses projetos. Então instalo eles.
Aqui. E aí, basicamente, o que eles ficam fazendo, né?
Eles têm um loop.
O que esse loop faz, né?
Aí. Eu não vou entrar nos detalhes aqui, senão ficaria duzentos e cinquenta dias conversando com vocês. Acreditem.
Tem história. Tem muita história pra contar.
Então eu tenho novas chegadas no backlog. O backlog chega e assim por diante. As tarefas são quebradas.
Os cortes são feitos e atualizações são feitas.
Então isso roda hoje.
Hoje. Isso é cem autônomo.
Só para vocês terem uma ideia. Só quero abrir a cabeça de vocês, tá.
Vou abrir um pouquinho a cabeça de vocês.
Tudo isso aqui é autônomo.
Então imagina o seguinte. O que eu faço, né? Imagina que eu tenho um backlog.
Que é gerado todo dia.
Chega um backlog pra mim. Aqui tá.
E aí, o que eu faço hoje.
E aí todo mundo pergunta pra mim assim.
Carlin. Como você consegue trabalhar em várias coisas ao mesmo tempo, caralho? Parece que você tem duzentos horas no dia. Enfim.
Não é porque eu gasto tempo.
Enquanto muita gente está gastando tempo fazendo negócio. Eu estou gastando muito tempo em criar uma arquitetura para fazer para mim, principalmente agora.
Eu sempre pensei assim. Mas agora, bicho.
Dá para fazer? Sinistramente tudo.
Entendeu? Eu consegui tocar quatro, cinco projetos de consultoria hoje, tranquilamente.
Por quê? Eu tenho uma Engines.
Então já vou dando a fita para vocês. Aqui tá.
Eu chamo ela de Work Realm.
Que é um outro projeto que eu trabalho, que eu tenho internamente.
Então esse projeto tá beleza. Vocês perguntaram demais. Deixa eu explicar aqui. Na verdade, vocês não perguntaram, mas acho que é Legal Pra Abrir A Cabeça De Vocês Tá.
Só para vocês entenderem. Um fluxo maduro. Hoje de trabalho.
Então hoje eu tenho uma Engines.
Que tem um loop.
Todo dia. De manhã, ela vai.
é acionada. Por mais que eu solta a carta aqui, meu filho, só se eu trabalhar para vocês.
O que vocês tiveram aqui. Isso aqui tudo. Eu descobri. Fui quebrando, trabalhando. Eu não conversei. Não teve Ning que Passou Isso Aqui Não.
Então vocês têm pelo menos o escopo.
Daí vocês se viram.
Por exemplo, eu estou tocando um projeto lá do Agent Context Protocol. é o cara. Eu quero saber se é relevante.
Se lançou uma coisa nova.
Se eu preciso ajustar o projeto, o produto.
Se existe alguma melhoria que precisa ser feita, se precisa uma otimização. Por exemplo, vou dar um exemplo de projeto, mesmo.
Work realm detectou pra mim, cara. Muito foda isso, né?
Eu sou apaixonado por isso aqui. Por essas coisas que eu crio, tem que ter paciência. Mas eu sou apaixonado.
Work Realm que identificou o Wakef pra.
Você tem noção do que é isso?
Eu tenho um agendamento.
Que acontece de tempos em tempos. Então, por exemplo.
Toda semana, quinta feira. Wookel me desperta.
E ele vai lá. Faz uma pesquisa.
Em sete animes diferentes.
Procurando informações no contexto do meu projeto.
Então ele vai lá, pô a Curve pô a Curve é um projeto de fábrica que transforma. Ele já sabe isso. Tá.
Que ele transforma. Olha a sacada que ele transforma Python para.
Transforma arquivos Tss para Python.
Que joga no Data Breaks. Ele tem um contexto do projeto.
E daí? Ele vai lá, dispara quinta feira e faz uma pesquisa cara.
Com vários itens, várias vertentes. Aí ele joga várias vertentes. Pô.
O que eu posso fazer para otimização de código.
Eu tenho que atualizar a celas.
Eu tenho que fazer tal tal tal? Ele manda essas pesquisas inteiras para várias llms. Eu uso Woman aqui por Debaixo Dos Panos Para Fazer Isso.
Então, my pai, chama. Na verdade, aqui não, né? Desculpa. Aqui quem faz isso? é Workhelmann.
Ele que faz a.
Ele vai lá. Manda pelo Open. Aí tá.
Mais Open router.
Mais Open router que aí eu tenho todos os modelos disponíveis, né?
E daí? O que ele faz, né? Ele vem aqui.
Aparece, chupetão.
Tal fez a pesquisa? Joga a pesquisa aqui pra mim.
E daí?
Ritel.
Foi, Luan? Tudo bem. Olha só.
Tem esses itens aqui no backlog para esse projeto? Quais que você quer.
Quais que você quer aceitar. E aí.
Walk F. Nasceu assim um mês atrás. Mais ou menos quatro semanas, cinco semanas.
Ele chegou e falou: olha, seu repositório está scattered.
Documentação tá outdated.
A Google acabou de lançar o Okf.
E eu acho que faz muito sentido você implementar na Curve. Você aprova.
E eu falei: Aprova o que ele faz? Ele vem aqui.
E escreve a tarefa para mim dentro do repositório.
E aí eu tenho um agendamento, uma automação dentro desse repositório que acorda e implementa feature for me.
Isso aqui é foda. Isso aqui é muito fod.
Então imagina que enquanto a galera está dormindo.
Você não está trabalhando.
Don't aí eu começo a ter, tipo.
Dez de produtividade, como eu falei para vocês, né?
Eu queria a fábrica justamente para poder não ter que ficar fazendo manualmente várias coisas ao mesmo tempo.
Meu computador fica ligado vinte e quatro por sete. Eu uso meu computador. Ainda.
Entendeu?
Então é assim que eu faço. Por isso que eu consigo trabalhar em vários projetos.
E aí o que eu uso, tá? Só te dando só dando a dica aqui de um milhão de reais.
Quem faz esse controle pra mim? Eu tenho uma camada de controle em cima de todos os meus projetos, tá? Todos Eles São Controlados Pelos Grok Bots.
Exclusivo. Eu não tive tempo de olhar para os meus amiguinhos hoje.
Eu tenho um chifre de staff que controla tudo pra mim. Mas eu posso ver aqui o que aconteceu no Meu Backlog Por Exemplo.
Então, obviamente que eu quero conversar com o Chief de staff.
E o shift de staff vai perguntar para todos os meus.
Botes, o que cada um é. E eu tenho um bote aqui.
Sure achar ele especificamente.
Eu tenho um que registra todas as atividades dentro do linear.
Eu tenho Works Researcher. Está vendo.
Então, Task Spec pick One.
And release already roster wire linear.
Próxima cut release e ele vai me dando aqui. Qual que eu quero? Tá vendo.
Ele vai buscando essas informações. Então eu perguntei aqui para o Chief do staff.
O Griffin está nisso, né? Então, o Griffin vai buscar as informações do backlog.
Do linear para ver o que tem.
Não vê.
No open to do pulling the food boards in this week's probes. Vamos puxar o pub.
Então assim aqui, ó, as tarefas já foram concluídas, né?
Então se eu for, por exemplo, aqui no Task Spec. Deixa eu ver se eu tenho uma nova atividade. Foi feita.
Tem um poor requests aqui. Tá vendo?
é tipo isso depressivo desse jeito. Tá gente.
Que eu nem sei que aconteceu na minha vida, mas chegou um pro Request aí. Obviamente que ele não vai Ser Analisado Por Mim.
Eu tenho um agente que vai fazer isso, que é o nosso. Qual o nome dele?
São muita gente aqui. Desculpa, eu tenho que me situar.
Cadê o Mussel Works?
Dash. Daqui a pouco ele abre ali.
Ele já testou aqui o Ci Beleza só fazer um Merge.
E aí vai aí o que acontece? Várias camadas.
Entendeu? Inclusive eu tô pra fazer um treinamento sobre o meu sistema de trabalho, que é basicamente isso aqui.
Como construir tudo do zero. Então você vai empilhando camada em cima de camada. Eu já tenho todas essas camadas definidas.
Então deu pra sacar. Então eu tenho Research. Que acontecem.
Eu decido o que vai acontecer. Implemento nos meus projetos inteiros.
Quebra implementa de forma autônoma. Eu fui construindo pedaço a pedaço, que é o que vocês estão aprendendo aqui.
Um conjunto disso.
Então isso é você conseguir.
Ser diferente. é isso.
Não é sobre, Ah, pô. Eu sou super inteligente. é só você parar e falar, porra, porra.
é trabalho em vários projetos.
Eu quero ser mais produtivo. Calma aí. Um passo para trás e fazer.
às vezes você já sabe que tem que ser feito. Você só não tem o tempo. A paciência.
E é muita coisa acontecer ao mesmo tempo.
Então, assim.
Uma das coisas que.
Eu tenho aqui.
Inclusive é sobre o que eu chamo de adoles, né?
Que eu já falei sobre ele, inclusive, mas acho que muita gente não entendeu.
Waidos. Para mim, é o meu agentec Development Operation System. Então eu vou criar esse sistema inteiro. Então eu crio ele.
Do zero. Camada de conhecimento.
Camada autônoma. Camada de cockpit.
Camada de controle, e eu vou criando todos eles para os projetos.
E aí os frameworks vão se juntando tudo. E eu faço o quê? Um compounding? Eu junto tudo isso.
Faz sentido. Eu parei um pouco, até um pouquinho do que a gente ia falar. Mas faz sentido. Coloca aí que eu não.
Já dá para ajudar um pouquinho a desbloquear algumas coisas para vocês.
Como vocês podem trabalhar em vários projetos ao mesmo tempo.
Tá beleza. Então.
Vamos voltar aqui. Então isso é sobre loop.
Também. Esse é sobre loop. Tá.
é como você automatiza esses processos. Então, por exemplo, quando a gente olha para a Spec.
A espera, que é o início de tudo. Na minha opinião.
Não é o Prompt. é o Spec. Hoje.
Então você passa o Spec.
O contexto é se você olhar.
O contexto. Ele é a única camada. A única de todas elas.
Aonde o dado reside. Então isso é muito forte. Muito forte.
O dado reside no contexto.
Que está perto do modelo.
Depois você tem o Harness que a gente viu. Os guardrails, os Bindings, os privilégios.
O loop.
Tente a ver agora como a gente encapsula tudo isso.
E aí, exatamente o Tiago falou: pô, é por isso que o cara tem trinta assinaturas de duzentos dólares. Exatamente isso.
Então, por exemplo, o cara fala, porra, muita gente já falou assim. Você não usa todas as suas assinaturas. Eu Uso Todas As Minhas Assinaturas.
Dificilmente. Eu acabo uma semana assim. Sempre fica ali no talo.
Porque eu uso para várias coisas diferentes. Para gerenciar várias coisas diferentes.
Então eu uso bastante.
E aí, por exemplo, hoje eu devo pagar aproximadamente sete, oito mil reais de assinatura.
Tranquilamente de Ia. Aí. Você fala pra mim, porra! Mas vale a pena, cara. Vale muito a pena por mim.
Eu devo fazer dez x mais em cima disso.
Porque o que eu consigo, por exemplo, um exemplo muito simples disso é.
Porra na pífia. Era pra eu estar entregando o projeto agora, no dia trinta e um. Mas eu já entreguei esse projeto há três meses atrás. Ele já está feito há três meses atrás. Essa semana que eu tive que trabalhar para ajustar alguns detalhes. Então, assim.
Eu deixei a fábrica fazendo validei com o cliente, me comuniquei.
Acho que vocês não conseguem ter dimensão. Um projeto de quatro meses. Eu fiz em duas semanas, e o outro Tempo Inteiro Eu Estou Aqui Fazendo Um Workshop Com Vocês.
Eu estou trabalhando. Eu estou fazendo outras coisas. Estou fazendo outros projetos.
Entende? Então vocês vão conseguir fazer exatamente a mesma coisa. E é isso que eu quero ensinar para vocês.
A mente para incomodar vocês. Para que vocês possam olhar para os Frameworks de vocês.
Comparar com o que você está aprendendo e fazer o seu melhor.
Porque com isso aqui você fala, pô, mas aqui se encaixa. Legal. Vou usar esse pedaço. Vou grudar aqui. Vou Fazer Assim Pô Já Vou Usar Isso Aqui Que Tá Feito Do Luan.
Vou implementar uma outra camada aqui.
Existem várias formas de você fazer.
Então essa é a grande parada de ser um Ai Nets. E vendem dinheiro. é só isso que se você Sair Desse Booticamp Com Isso.
Você ganhou o tempo inteiro.
é o Mindset. E sempre é sobre o Mindset. Toda virada de chave. é sobre o Mindset.
Se você olhar o problema de um prisma diferente, moderno.
Você vai resolver.
Tá, então.
Hoje Cara é Impossível Te Colocar Em Um Problema Que Você Não Vai Conseguir Resolver Quase As Não é Possível que você com três tipos de as diferentes Qumy Cloud Codec. Você não consiga sair do outro lado. Você consegue sair do outro lado.
Então coloca isso na sua cabeça.
é a forma como você guia llm à conclusão dela.
Beleza. Acho que o ponto é não tentar ser o Luan é porque ninguém consegue ser o Luan. Ninguém consegue Ser O Lucas Ninguém Consegue Ser O Diego.
Ninguém consegue ser o Tiago. Eu gostaria de ser muitas pessoas que eu admiro em várias áreas.
Mas não, você vai ter que ser. O que é você pegando essas coisas, né?
Então, quando eu estou ali, por exemplo, vou viajar agora. Eu vou passar três dias com o meu Field City Hall Que Eu Trabalho.
Eu vou passar três dias.
Tomando café da manhã.
Tendo papos durante o dia e saindo à noite para jantar e curtir um pouco, conversar.
Com o Tim de Sales, com o cliente e com o meu feedcow que cobra mil dólares a hora.
Caralho. Eu estou do lado de um cara.
Que o valor de mercado dele custa mil dólares a hora.
Porra. Você tem noção que é você poder sentar do lado do cara? é um privilégio.
E eu olho isso com olhos de cara. Quão sortudo eu sou?
Para poder sentar. Porque o cara falar cara.
Isso aqui. Como está funcionando? Como você está indo nas reuniões dos clientes? Como os clientes estão se comportando.
E como que está acontecendo isso e tal. E cara, essa conversa que eu pego, aquilo ali.
Isso vale mais do que qualquer dinheiro que eu invista.
Ou eu investiria dez mil. Vinte mil dólares dentro de uma conversa dessa. Porque eu sei. Porque eu já fiz Isso Muitas Vezes Muitos Anos.
Que são essas conversas que transformam a sua mente.
E o que você precisa para mudar de emprego, para ser melhor e para evoluir como profissional.
é só uma coisa, na verdade. Desculpa. Duas coisas é despertar o seu Mindset. E se colocar numa zona.
Que sai da sua zona de conforto, ou seja, um ambiente diferente que te incomode. é só isso que você precisa.
Porque é natural do ser humano.
Se adaptar a um problema e vencer nele.
Esse é o nosso comportamento natural. A gente vai querer.
Superar aquilo de uma forma ou de outra. Isso é do ser humano.
Então se você tem o Mindset.
Ou seja, pô, eu vi isso aqui. Tudo.
Beleza. Agora eu vou me colocar num ambiente.
Total incômodo. é a mesma coisa. Pô hoje eu sou referência na Piffhan de Ya.
é muito legal olhar hoje e falar. Porra legal! Luan, responde hoje por tudo de a.
Conversa com o presidente da empresa. Chegou nesse ponto. Pô beleza legal. Mas são doze anos construindo isso.
E são doze anos. Eu me tirando da porra.
Da minha zona de conforto. Eu faço isso desde que eu trabalho pra fora.
Eu nunca vivi um ambiente que eu sento e falar. Nossa, que delícia! Deixa eu curtir aqui não é sempre Uma Arma Na Cabeça.
E aí você tem prós. Você tem contras. Tudo tem pró e contra.
Aí vai ver o que você quer. E aí, cara? A grande questão é: você vai viver coisas muito legais por causa disso.
Então eu acho que é isso que vocês têm que entender.
O que torna um profissional valioso. São as experiências que ele carrega.
Então, às vezes a galera chega para mim, porra! Me dá um desconto num treinamento desse.
Porra! Uma formação de três quinhentos reais, porra! Tá caro.
Cara. Se você tem dinheiro, paga essa porra.
Paga de olho fechado. Porque não? é sempre sobre o conteúdo.
é sobre o que aquilo vai te desbloquear.
Então muita gente não entende isso. O cara está parado no dinheiro, mas na verdade, se você parar pra pensar Quanto Que Vale Um Booticamp Desse Realmente.
Ele vale muito mais que R um setecentos reais. Muito mais que Rdois. Mil reais.
Na verdade.
Se você for olhar a realidade.
Eu estou indo para passar três dias no cliente.
Por vinte mil dólares. Eu estou entregando a mesma coisa que eu vou entregar para eles. é basicamente eu vou Entregar Pedaços Desse Treinamento Aqui Para O Cliente.
E a Fifa tá cobrando em cima disso. Vinte mil dólares para fazer isso.
Em três dias de treinamento. Então assim vai muito do valor percebido que você tem.
A questão é, ache o lugar correto para investir o dinheiro. é só sobre isso.
Pode ser com o Luan. Pode não ser com o Luan.
Pode ser com outras pessoas muito boas que tem no mercado.
Dentro e fora. Mas gaste dinheiro com a educação. Gaste dinheiro com treinamento.
Eu me perguntava, caralho, treinamento vai deixar de existir, cara? Não, cada vez vai existir mais.
Mais e mais focado.
Que te traga esse tipo de insight desses nuggets para você falar e implementar com a experiência vivida.
Então, cara, compra um treinamento de três mil dólares, compra um treinamento de cara. O que o seu dinheiro permitir, invista em educação.
Porque eu nunca vi até hoje alguém investir em educação e se foder. Eu nunca vi até hoje. Eu nunca vi.
Você pode comprar errado.
Investir errado aí. Beleza.
Mas se você literalmente aproveitar, porque, assim sendo, bem, sincerão mesmo.
Vou. Aproveitamento. Não está no professor te passando. é você que escolhe aproveitar o treinamento ou não, né?
Eu falei isso ontem ontem. A galera. Ah, porra! Eu quero cancelar o booticamp. Porque.
Tem muita prática.
A mesma pessoa que falou que tinha pouca prática.
Então não é sobre mim. é sobre a pessoa, entendeu?
Então eu quero que vocês entendam.
Que.
Escolha. Pessoas que são referências.
E andem com elas. Vejam elas. Eu tenho as minhas referências. Eu tenho as pessoas que eu corro atrás. Eu Tenho As Pessoas Que Eu Converso Eu Tenho As Pessoas Que Eu Admiro.
E eu faço questão de manter.
Sinistramente esse link todo dia, toda semana.
Fora e dentro da Patient. E eu pago para isso. Eu tenho um grupo de mentoria.
Então assim pô. Não é só vocês que pagam mentoria, não é só vocês que pagam treinamento. Eu também pago Treinamento Pra Estar Na Frente Para Poder Trazer Isso Para Vocês Num Valor.
Que vocês podem consumir, porque o valor que eu pago para o conteúdo.
Que, sendo bem sincero, não vou ser humilde agora, mas.
Muitas das vezes, cara. Muito aquém do que eu esperava.
A maioria das vezes muito aquém.
E a gente entrega um conteúdo que tanto é que tanta gente trabalhando para fora, diz exatamente isso.
This, cara cara. O que vocês entregam aqui em português é simplesmente Mind Blowing total.
Então, assim.
O que eu quero que vocês entendam é qual a intenção aqui.
Greed era muito bom, mas a minha intenção é tesão. A minha intenção é estar aqui com febre fodida, explicando Para Vocês Porque Eu Sei Que Eu Posso Mudar A Vida De Vocês.
Eu posso não mudar a vida de vocês. Eu posso.
Jogar alguma coisa que dê algum gatilho na sua cabeça que te desbloqueia alguma coisa. Então é sobre isso.
Tá? Então passe esses quatro dias e reflita sobre isso.
Vocês têm um repositório. Vocês têm tudo gravado. Vocês têm as recomendações. Vocês têm um Mindset.
Ande do lado de pessoas que estão à sua frente. Logo você se tornará essas pessoas.
Bem, voltando. Desculpe pelo.
Saindo um pouquinho aqui. Deu uma alucinada na Llm.
Mas beleza. Depois eu volto aqui para ler um pouquinho. Do que vocês falaram?
Mas a gente vai passar por todos eles, tá?
E aí, o que é um objetivo, né? Se você viu lá.
No meu Grocols, no Groc.
Eu dei um barragou, né.
Então o que é o bar? Gol, né? O Barrag é o Bubble Bubble rapping, né? Então lembra que eu falei o seguinte.
O Harness.
Ele automaticamente. Ele já seta.
Para o modelo seguinte. Olha.
Você está dentro de um ambiente.
Você tem esse estudozinhos para fazer aqui?
E você tem que completar eles.
E o Harness está instruindo. Ele.
Que fazer o que não fazia assim por diante.
Agora.
Um outro processo. é o loop.
Loop. é, eu estou olhando Harness.
E o Harness está operando numa outra camada e eu venho lá em cima e falo o seguinte. Olha, Harness.
Além do que você falou para a Ln fazer?
Eu quero falar. O que llm tem que fazer.
Então eu vou lá, exceto um objetivo para ele.
So um minutinho que eu estou aqui com a garganta. Só ouro.
Então o certo? Um objetivo para ele.
Então eu falo, cara.
Fica trabalhando até os testes passarem.
Até o Beautiful for verde.
Cara. Faz isso aqui. Até.
O link estiver limpo, pô, faz isso aqui até a migração estiver funcionando e tiver respondido.
Duzentos. Tá.
Pô. Faz o objetivo quando todas as suítes de teste estiverem checadas a zero.
Ou você pode ter uma Skill que você escreve um objetivo, e ele faz um.
Um prompt enhancement.
Em cima disso, né? Uma forma de vocês fazerem isso, por exemplo, é pelo Crisp.
Desculpa pelo Whisperflow.
Então, se vocês usam o Speflow, por exemplo.
Deixa eu mostrar aqui.
Quem usa Whisperflow para falar.
O que você pode fazer? Você pode vir aqui no Spflow.
Vem, transforme.
E você vem aqui. Criou um novo.
Você coloca aqui. Goal.
E aí você escolhe qual é o Q tres.
Deixa eu ver.
Opt. Calma aí, então, vamos lá.
Opt.
Opt três gol.
Beleza. E aí eu falo o seguinte.
Queria para mim quando eu falar isso assim, assim, assim.
E aí, na hora que você falar, você aperta e se transforma. E ele transforma aquele testinho.
Que você cairia um objetivo bem simplinho num puto objetivo de gol legal.
é uma forma de você fazer.
Tá vendo? A cabeça vai começando a achar várias nuances do que você pode fazer.
Isso é legal. Eu acho isso legal.
Então o Goal é um objetivo em cima do Harness.
Então, na prática.
O Cloud tem o Harness.
Dele. O Cloud Coach tem um Harness dele.
Beleza. Então ele tem os próprios objetivos e as coisas dele. E ele tem um gol que você pode estabelecer Em Cima Disso Fala Cara Eu Quero Que Você Faça Isso Sim Assim Assado.
Então é isso que vai acontecer. Você vai ter.
Capacidade de falar para ele.
Qual é o objetivo.
Beleza.
A gente passou, né? Durante essa semana. Falando.
Da captura da intenção quebra no Task Spec Cayas Adrs para saber exatamente o que você vai fazer. Pequenas.
Bem acionáveis, específicas.
Depois a gente decompôs com sinuais e.
A gente fez um consenso rápido.
Depois a gente gerou as Tasks. O que a gente vai fazer hoje? A gente vai registrar.
A gente ia fazer o binding de assinalar.
O nosso Harness. E a gente vai executar essas atividades. Tá.
Então a primeira coisa que a gente viu e a gente entendeu isso, inclusive que existe.
Como você dita no Prompt. E como você enforça isso.
Então, se você quer criar um Grad rail ou um binding correto.
Você não vai criar esse binding incorreto.
Só um minuto.
Você não vai criar esse bande incorreto.
Em um ritmo, em um arquitetura em um Asians Md num Cloud Md.
Você não vai. Você vai ter que criar um sandbox para isso. O Hardness é sobre isso. Criar um sendbox.
Proporcionar permissões corretas e assim por diante.
E a interface de escrita do que você vai fazer? Ela está literalmente vinculada ao conhecimento que você precisa. Nesse caso, nosso aqui.
A gente construiu da primeira parte que a gente viu até o dia três.
Todas as tarefas.
Do tipo um. Mas a gente parou na orquestração. Hoje a gente vai desbloquear essa orquestração.
Que é com o Dexter.
Tá? Então a gente vai executar o converge. A gente vai olhar para o Sinwise novamente.
A gente vai olhar de novo. O Task Spec.
A gente vai ver o Taskmash rapidamente.
E a gente vai ver um board do linear funcionando.
Fim a fim, tá.
Lembrando que o que eu quero que vocês saiam aqui desse treinamento também. E achem essas oportunidades de conversa.
Na sua empresa.
Contexto.
Contexto, pode estudar contexto. Tá.
Tranquilamente.
Não só aqui, né? Existem outros também.
Pode estudar contexto, porque contexto é uma coisa muito legal. E vocês vão conseguir tirar muita coisa legal disso. Aqui.
Então vamos dar uma olhadinha no que a gente vai fazer.
Hoje, né.
Então deixa eu só puxar aqui.
Vocês quiserem me acompanhar.
Fiquem à vontade.
Para quem quiser.
Tá aí?
Run D quatro.
Prompt Recap.
Vamos fazer um prompt recap.
Então, o que a gente quer fazer, né?
Tipo: vamos olhar.
A parte de Landing.
Lake House e o Golden Match.
Vamos ver sobre o valor do trail de cento e setenta e tres. Quarenta e quatro.
Verificar se esses valores foram implementados. Se esse processo foi implementado corretamente no dia anterior.
Então a gente quer fazer um prompt de recap do Gold.
Para verificar se existe uma prova.
De que a gente conseguiu garantir na evidência.
De reconciliação, esse número.
Esse a gente olhar essa reconciliação.
E a gente vê aqui.
Golden Match.
Eu tenho aceitação.
E se eu vier no final? Starask, ele sucedeu.
Só que eu não tenho aqui. Cadê Cadê o meu evidência? Cadê o meu reconciliação, tá? Ele vai gerar agora.
Gold Quest. Through Modern Park True True.
Outcome class rejected Resolved Type One.
Então aqui a gente tem quando há evidência executada, né?
A gente tem um resultado dela.
Se a gente vier aqui em Reconciliation.
A gente tem os valores que bateram corretamente.
Da tradução. Então eu quero saber exatamente isso. Então deixei executar aqui.
Então a gente vai verificar se as informações. Se a tradução que a gente fez do valor mínimo.
Do primeiro tipo que foi a tradução.
That's in Chinese. Se a gente vê em Modern.
A gente teve a ingestão.
Com as implementações do cartão.
O primeiro tipo.
A gente teve.
Lake House com Dlt, puxando essas informações com Ductb. A gente teve.
O Dbt.
Bronze, Silver.
E Gold. Com essa informação.
A gente teve scripts de validação.
Dessa informação.
E a gente tem um script que faz o que aqui.
Ele reconstrói.
Todas as camadas.
Gerar evidência. Está vendo?
Tem isso que esse cara faz.
Tv executar esse cara aqui pra verificar se a evidência está correta. O que é evidência.
A evidência, basicamente, executar todos os nossos processos.
Ingerir camada Landing jogar no banco de dados. A evidência, enfim.
E verificar se esse valor está correto.
Do que a gente fez ou não.
Com a nossa camada de tradução e verificar se está tudo certo.
Bateu cento e setenta e três. Então isso quer dizer que é o valor esperado do documento.
Luan. Como que eu sei isso, lembra.
Que a gente tem as especificações aqui.
E a gente tem um samples.
Dos arquivos com os valores. Então essa tradução tem que bater outra coisa. A gente tem aqui.
Contrato, né? Então, por exemplo, o contrato do tipo um.
Então aqui são exatamente os valores que a gente espera sobre eles.
Nem sempre a gente tem essas informações.
A priori. Mas a ideia é que você sempre consiga ter essas informações. Tá.
Então, o que ele falou aqui.
Custo. Está presente.
Está faltando só a última parte. Landing.
Então a gente tem aqui Landing.
Cadê.
Modern.
Por que eu não estou vivendo o Landing.
Eu tô doido aqui.
I hate nossa, estava morrendo aqui. Agora, Landing, que não está comentado, tá? é o arquivo que caiu.
Olha que legal! Então, Landing.
O arquivo que caiu chamado um parque. Dá uma olhada.
Binate. File ali. Não lê parque. Obrigado, mas ele lê aqui o chá. Beleza.
Qual é o arquivo parquê? Deixa eu ver se consigo.
Abrir ele para a gente ver.
Eu acho que não tenho.
Police can see coming.
Não é possível que eu não consiga abrir ele em nenhuma aplicação.
Que vergonha, cara. Não tenho.
Publicação. Para lipar. Quê?
Vocês devem ter. E se vocês executarem que é o visual Studio Code, ele abre, por exemplo.
é? Não tem nada hoje.
Quem diria, hein.
Não tenho mais. Eu posso pedir.
é? Posso usar uma celai também.
Sua preguiça mesmo. Estou ficando preguiçoso.
Tá? Então ele mostrou aqui.
Beleza. Cadê deixa eu voltar.
A gente também tem o dado no Lake House.
Modern Lake House.
Ductb.
Northwind está aqui. Também não consigo ler esse cara, né?
Mas o dado está aqui.
Quem conseguir.
Dá para utilizar também o Cli do Dunk.
E a gente tem evidência.
Evidence.
Modern B zero um.
Golden Match.
Contrato de reconciliação.
Presente na Gold. O legado bate valor.
Também aceito.
Lindo, né? Então a gente construiu a parada aqui? Exatamente. Faz.
O que o javo faz.
Com perfeição no nível de Golden.
Beleza. Agora, vamos dar uma olhada. Seguinte.
Vamos dar uma olhada em.
Tudo no trail todinho no processo, como um todo.
Então vamos dar uma olhada seguinte. Vou mandar aqui.
Vamos focar.
Na parte de entender os requisitos que foram gerados no primeiro dia.
Os problemas que haviam.
As decisões que foram tomadas.
A linha de engenharia de software.
A linha de engenharia de dados e Analytics. E o que a gente vai desenvolver hoje.
Então, basicamente, é para a gente olhar tudo que a gente decidiu e conversou ao longo dos dias. Tá.
é que a gente vai executar? Só o dois.
Que é exatamente isso que eu estou executando. Não, eu estou no três, já, né?
Não é isso mesmo.
Todos eles. Beleza.
Olá.
Northwind explicou qual o metadado do dado.
As colunas. Olha que linda.
O Decimal dezoito, doze.
A linha zero, por exemplo, transação.
Mexan, Tolkien.
Caralho! Que foda, né, mascarado.
O valor, movimentação.
Código de autorização terminal.
São ser recorde.
Ou zero hall, um.
Todos com settlement movement, code e cosp.
Totalizando cento e setenta e três, quarenta e cinco.
Legal.
But.
Aqui a gente vai responder aqui.
What is the Show, resolver os comentários que vocês colocarem. Quando eu estava.
Delirando aqui.
A gente. Caldwan foi foda.
Não, Ice Pac foi foda.
Sim, eu ainda uso ferramentas como Graphify, Main Palace.
Só que tudo dentro dos processos, né? Então é o que eu falei.
O que eu faço, né? Agora eu tenho um framework.
Então, por exemplo, você perguntou: dentro do converge, tem Cropify dentro do converge, temem Palace.
Porque o que eu faço? Eu vou nesses projetos. Eu olho ele e falo. Pô beleza. é o Memory. Leia.
Pô, eu tenho um certo Memory Layer aqui.
Beleza. Então faz o seguinte. Pega as paradas daqui e traz pra cá.
é isso?
Vamos ver se agora vai.
Ah, você está zoando. Calma aí, gente.
Aconteceu uma coisa muito triste aqui.
Só um minuto. Aqui, eu converge.
Que é o senhor? Task.
Tá aqui só para mostrar o que eu estou fazendo.
O.
O Simax. Eu gosto de utilizar.
Para fazer algumas coisas mais como que eu posso dizer.
Para fazer algumas coisas mais autônomas.
Então o que eu estou fazendo aqui? Eu estou com três sessões abertas.
Um pro Task spec. Uma, proximize um para converge. Porque o que eu estou fazendo.
Doutor. Gerando aqui dentro de ebooks.
Um Ebook completo de Pdf.
Sobre o converge, por exemplo, que.
Não converge, não converge. Está pequeno. Vou pegar aqui um grande.
Pegar o The Book do Task Spec.
A Book Tech está com sessenta linhas. Está vendo.
So I'm gonna keep.
Então, o que eu faço nos finais de semana?
O que eu faço na sexta feira. O que eu faço.
No tempo livre. O que eu faço quando estou viajando? é isso que eu faço. Quando pegar um avião, ficar Seis Horas No Avião.
Eu vou ler. O que? Que.
Alguns pontos para ter melhores insights. Eu vou ler o projeto da Curv.
Novamente, para ver se eu consigo pegar mais alguma coisa. Melhorar alguma coisa. Então é isso.
Você vai gerando vários insights dentro de insights, para poder ir pensando em novas coisas.
Então é sobre isso?
Então vamos ver aqui. ó.
Bem. O mapa dos sistemas. Duas plantas. O sim. Um.
Okay, qual foi a questão? A questão foi olhar o tipo um.
Na perspectiva inteira do problema. Requisito problema, decisão, engenharia de.
De software de engineering.
Ai. E o que a gente vai fazer essa noite, então? Duas plantas.
Led Sftp no Sim, a gente vai ingerir.
Land. Traduzir no Sin Ii é Dlt e Gold.
Hoje a gente vai fazer os loops para escrever todas as outras, né?
A gente tem os Business requirement documentos que viraram Tech Spec. Depois que viraram Adrs.
E que são colocadas dentro daqui. Depois disso, foram Sims.
Esses arquivos entraram em consenso.
Depois, cinco arquivos foram gerados de parcer.
Depois arquivos gerados por Lake House para Gold. Qual o fluxo, né?
A planta existe porque a Helena quer reconstruir.
Esses arquivos fora do Java.
O dinheiro cai do mesmo jeito.
Só que não como Api, o dinheiro é aceitado. A gente tem um contrato do que julgo que é certo E Errado E Spec Onde Vem Todos Os Documentos Que A Gente Recebe Para Fazer Essas Conversões.
Citado no documento.
Enfim, beleza.
Qual o problema, né? O problema é que a gente tem duas plantas. O Tipo um tem um Taylor de Cento E Sessenta E Tres Quarenta E Quatro Em Alguns Casos Versa Cento E Quarenta E Cinco.
Nesse é declarado.
O que refusa o Bet.
Independente do que vai acontecer, a gente não vai inventar respostas que a gente tem que fazer. Se a gente tiver essa informação.
E olhar para ela citado aqui. Quais foram as decisões que nós fizemos.
O que. Que é, Frozen? O que pode ser feito? O que está no Lake House? O que não está citado aqui também.
Quando a gente olha para a linha da engenharia de software, da ingestão ao Landing.
Emitiu a melhor prática de modelagem.
De modo eu passar Scheme, Writer e Handler, que é uma prática de modelagem de arquiteturas.
Givens Riven e passe essas informações dentro da tarefa que está aqui, inclusive.
Citado aqui também.
Na parte de de Engineering.
Fazer toda a parte. Puxar esse dado, colocar no Duck Lake, fazer Bronze. Severity Gold.
No grão de Pet é de mais Curmen. Se fazer o Golden Match e validar contra a evidência.
Executar um Dbt Ran.
Para poder logar essas informações e ter certeza que esse cara vai funcionar. Videira da tarefa. Gold.
Para criar a camada Gold.
E víde referência. Também.
Gold. Cadê Cadê Gold.
Não perdi.
Aqui. Desculpa. Aqui Gold Match.
We. Ver se eu acho que eu quero aqui.
Ainda não estou feliz.
Desenvolve. Estou feliz com esse volume, tá? Depois.
Hoje, a gente vai colocar tudo no loop e executar esse processo inteiro, né?
O que está certo e errado.
A gente tem que conseguir.
Garantir que a gente.
Identificar o problema.
A primeira escrita vai ser na Landing.
Na engenharia. A gente vai trabalhar com décimo como engenheiro. A gente vai reconstruir isso de forma.
A moderna. A gente tem o Golden Match para verificar se o dado está correto.
A gente vai desenhar o Lineage depois. E a gente vai ter um pacote de evidências, tá.
Beleza. Então é isso realmente.
Vamos avançar. Dúvidas, podem perguntar aqui.
Eu não sei se sou muito burro, mas eu ainda tenho muita dificuldade de pensar em como eu construir as Coisas Que Têm Mostrado Aquilo.
Sig e tentando mais exemplo. Como é que extrai isso? Eu fico perdido na forma que tu usas as tuas criações.
Pensa no seguinte, tá.
Isso aprendi com Dan Instead.
Estava na minha. Essa questão.
As respostas já estão na nossa cabeça.
Muitas vezes. Vem alguém lá? Fala alguma coisa que desbloqueia.
Eu fui jantar com o Danny Instead. E aí.
Ele estava basicamente explicando um problema que ele resolveu.
A Secretaria de Estado dos Estados Unidos, que é uma parada de Dailyway Housing, que é uma parada gigantesca.
Que eles gastaram um mês para decompor a atividade em Small By Chunks.
E depois eles começaram a achar padrões. Então, qual foi o Thought Process dele? O processo dele.
Pegou o problema.
Entendeu? Qual é a taxonomia e a ontologia?
Depois ele abriu esse escopo, entendeu? Qual é o maior grão e o menor grão.
Depois ele começou a pegar essas atividades e decompor sem Iar. Tá.
Que é? O que é? O que o Swing Lane faz.
Decompôs todas essas atividades.
Criou relações e essas atividades que demorava meses. A gente faz em cinco minutos. é tipo: isso mesmo. é loucura, mas é verdade.
E ele começou a achar relação.
Como que isso traz para o dia a dia de você, cara. Você fez a coisa uma vez fez uma Coisa Duas. Fez Uma Coisa três, Quatro.
Pô beleza.
Eu estou fazendo isso aqui de forma repetitiva, várias vezes.
Beleza aí. A questão é isso aqui. Se eu automatizar isso, se eu pensar numa camada em cima disso.
Isso vai melhorar o meu processo. Então eu comecei.
Pensando dessa forma. Então eu olhava que o Prompt estava. Eu chegava. Era assim meu dia, né?
Algum tempo atrás. Era assim.
Eu tinha cinco projetos aqui no Cimax. Eu tinha mais.
Dez projetos aqui no Super Engineering.
E o dia a dia rolando. E eu vim aqui para optar em.
Depois pompitava em outro. Poupitava em outro.
Chegava no final do dia, eu estava. Parecia que eu ia ter um filho, né? De tanta dor. Aí eu falei: Pô.
Vou melhorar. Vou começar a falar.
Aí. Comecei a falar mais rápido aqui, aqui e tal.
Eu falei, caralho! Eu tô fazendo isso pra caralho! O que eu estou fazendo.
Aí eu parei para ver, e geralmente eu paro no final de semana, sábado e domingo, porque na semana correria Ou Na Sexta Sexta é Um Dia Que Eu Tento Sempre Ir.
Tirar para ter esses tipos de coisa.
E eu falei: Pô, eu preciso pô, eu tô recebendo requisito novo. Preciso fazer toda coisa que pôs para todos os projetos. Beleza.
Então eu vou criar um componente para poder fazer isso para mim.
Então pensa em componentes.
Pequeno. Porque o problema é o seguinte: você quer fazer uma parada gigante? Faz pequeno.
Pensei num componente para.
Fazer a tarefa. Depois pensei: um componente para poder trazer novas ideias. Depois pensei num componente para fazer isso.
E aí você vai construir seus componentes.
é? Por exemplo, Adilson falou uma coisa que vale muito dinheiro, né?
Criar um grupo para praticar isso. Então assim se você pega oitenta pessoas aqui.
Noventa, cem. Vocês entram dentro de um grupo e vocês começam a discutir sobre isso. Brainstorming.
O quantos valores isso gera para você?
Quanto de valor que você tem de pegar já amparada. Uma ideia de melhorar essa ideia.
E ter um insight do que o cara fez. Enfim, então eu gosto muito de grupo. Quando o grupo tem um objetivo.
Eu não participo de muitos grupos.
A ideia é essa.
Fica tranquilo que a gente vai resolver. Grupos, tá? De uma vez por outra, para quem estiver no The Plumbers, Que é A Nossa Comunidade.
Muita gente falou. Ela morreu. Não sei o que. Não. Muito pelo contrário. Ela fica mais foda do que vocês Imaginam Graças A Deus.
Então.
Aguentei mais um pouquinho. O que está chegando? Tá.
Só aguente.
Aguentem que vai dar muito bom.
Vai dar um muito bom mesmo. Tá.
Beleza. Então a gente viu.
Todo esse conteúdo aqui.
Agora a gente vai olhar.
O quê? Que o Sim Wise. O Sim Wise decidiu quebrar em três lanes, né?
Ele chamou a primeira jeans. Josh Lanning.
Pro. Tipo um. Depois ele chamou Tlt Gold Pro próximo Lane de de.
E depois ele chamou de Orchestrate. Serve para Swelene hoje que a gente vai fazer.
Que é a última camada que implementa a camada do Dagsster e a camada do fast Api. Tô bem animado Pra Ver Isso Inclusive.
Vamos ver se a gente consegue.
Implementar essa parágrafo.
Um binho. Aqui.
Vamos botar para a smirilar. Então.
Leia o documento de Sims.
We. Dr. Late Night Sparked.
Leia também o sim. Weisegett, Tml.
Não, recruta. Vê consensos, tá.
Draw One Table. Porque a gente agora vai fazer o seguinte.
A gente vai ver o tipo dois. O tipo tres o tipo quatro e o tipo cinco Orchestre.
Nos. Sim, Wise.
Então, agora o que a gente vai fazer.
A gente vai expandir.
O senhor Wise.
Que não está aqui, inclusive.
Eu não sei o que ele não autorizou, mas beleza.
E ele vai quebrar aqui.
Porque a gente tinha gerado só, tipo, um.
Agora a gente vai gerar, tipo dois, tipo três, tipo quatro.
A gente vai colocar as lênes novas.
Essa aqui é um trabalho bem interessante, tá? Que a gente vai começar a ver o que ele vai fazer aqui.
Então ele vai começar a cortar as novas linhas dos sistemas dos novos tipos, né?
Se a gente vier em Docs aqui Adrs.
So Because Cdrs vão começar a crescer consideravelmente.
Mas principalmente.
Se a gente olhar o cinza também. Que vão ser colocados, tá? Então a gente vai começar a quebrar essas informações aqui.
Perguntas quando ele faz.
Eu sinto falta dessas interações no dia a dia. Meu time é muito júnior. Então, no geral, sou puxado, cara.
Por isso que eu falo. Que comunidade? é uma parada muito foda.
Quem é que é do The Plumbers? Coloca aqui. Eu não sei se tem o Mini The Plumbers.
Aqui.
Bem. The Plumbers. Ele nasceu enquanto ele está executando aqui a gente vai conversando.
Então ele está aqui gerando. Olha que lindo! Que delícia. Eu adoro meus produtos. Desculpa, mas eu adoro.
Então ele está gerando a Landing aqui dos arquivos. Está vendo? Ele está cortando o Sims de novo.
Fazendo tudo isso, gerando.
Desculpa, porque eu fico muito.
Animado quando eu vejo tudo isso funcionando. Tá.
Então, o que acontece hoje? A gente tem.
O The Plumbers.
Que ficou muito tempo desatualizado.
E aí a gente tem pessoas de relação de amor e ódio no The Plumbers, né?
Que eu expliquei por que a gente fez essa segregação de Iá e não ia.
Na época, fazia muito sentido hoje, não faz? Obviamente que eu não estou no futuro.
To pé do futuro, mas não no futuro, mas, enfim, Long Story Short para reduzir.
O diplomas vai virar uma coisa só então a gente vai a partir de agora. Isso aqui inclusive, vai ser Anunciado Nas Próximas Semanas.
A gente vai ter uma estrutura com assinatura com três assinaturas diferentes.
E a essas assinaturas te dão níveis no sistema.
Só que. Qual a parada legal do que a gente fez agora.
Que agora não é discord, não é curseduca. Não é nada. é um sistema só. Então imagina que você vai Entrar Num Sistema Só.
Você vai ter comunidades. Você vai ter anúncio. Você vai ter toda a parte de comunicação. Você vai ter todos Os Vídeos Você Vai Ter Os Agentes.
Você vai ter tudo dentro de um lugar.
Tudo dentro de uma graça. Então você vai precisar sair de um lugar para consumir o conteúdo. Vai estar tudo Lá Então Vai Ter Comunidade De Tudo.
Vai ter comunidade de A. Vai ter comunidade. Enfim.
E o The Plumbers. Para quem estiver na maior assinatura, vai ter todos os conteúdos que a gente tem de bote camp.
Vai ter créditos para ter a formação e assim por diante.
E numa outra vertente de Ia. A gente tem a formação.
G. Ai did engineer, que é o que eu vou falar hoje, inclusive no finalzinho, para quem tem interesse.
Cara, se você quer ver tudo isso aqui em setenta horas.
Então, porra, tem aula de vol.
Eu vou mostrar. Aqui tem fundamento de tudo.
Então pô. Imagina pegar os fundamentos de tudo e rever o Boot camp.
Explosão, né? Porque aí você vai falar. Ah, porra! O Luan falou isso aqui.
Que eu não tinha pegado muito. Mas agora eu entendi.
Entendeu? Agora entend.
Então, beleza ele planejou aqui. Ele ainda não executou.
Ay só colocou beleza. A gente vai.
Botar o.
Desk Spec para esmirilar agora, né.
Então agora a gente vai. A gente gerou o Sins.
Os detalhes estão aqui.
De todos os tipos.
Não somente de um tipo. Agora.
E agora a gente vai.
Vim aqui.
E a gente vai gerar.
Agora, bicho. Vai pegar tanta.
Vamos ver se ele vai agora.
Então.
O que nós temos, né? Enquanto ele está gerando aqui? O que ele ia fazer? Ele criou o Sins, planejou.
E agora a gente vai começar a quebrar as tarefas, tá.
Para poder executar.
Que são os tipos? Dois, três, quatro e cinco, que é o tipo um. A gente já fez.
Só pra você entender que já existe uma inteligência do converge, né? Então ele vai fazer o mesmo processo que a gente fez.
Pegar o requisito, ler todo o Spec.
Quebrar no documento de negócio do documento de negócio, quebrar no documento técnico, no documento técnico decompor.
Criar. Sim, depois criar as Legs e agora gerar as tarefas para as tarefas serem.
Concluídas.
Enquanto ele faz isso aqui?
Hoje, né.
Como que a gente tem.
No sistema como um todo, né.
O que eu acreditaria que seria o próximo passo para você? Por exemplo.
Quem aqui já é da formação.
Teve acesso a esse Boot camp.
Então já tem acesso a esse bootcamp.
Então esse boot camp inclusive, é um booticamp que não foi anunciado no currículo da formação.
Mas eu resolvi dar para todo mundo, dentro da formação.
Para que a gente não tivesse o problema de canibalização. Como todo mundo falava que havia. Tá, então.
O que você vai ter dentro da plataforma.
Você vai ter o Mindset.
Que eu acho que pra mim, é um dos vídeos. São os vídeos mais interessantes aqui. Na minha opinião.
Que eu vou exatamente? Sabe, essa apagação de sapo boa aqui que eu fiz.
Então eu passo umas duas horas. Falando disso em escala como um todo.
Beleza. Então a gente tem isso. Depois a gente tem fundamentos. O ler um.
Então fundamentos de ar prompt de dinheiro e contexto engineering.
Hit Revenue, reggae. Agentes.
Memória. Protocolo Dna.
Spec Driven llm opposition swaps.
A gente tem que ter engineering, segurança e guardrails, Frameworks. Esses vídeos do Rafa.
Se vocês verem sobre vol puta que pariu! Ai, Coding.
Fine intent versus reggae.
Versus Long Context, por exemplo, pegar um vídeo aqui do Rafa de de voz.
Por exemplo, ele explica literalmente o que é um Eval. Como que é gerado.
Porque e aí ele tem.
Ele tem o Ademo que ele mostra os Assets. Como funciona todo o processo.
Cara. Aonde tá? No tracing? Como funciona? Como que você faz.
E aí o Rafa? Acho que é uma das pessoas que eu conheço hoje. Que mais sabe de voz? Porque Ele Trabalhou Num Projeto De Voz.
Fugidamente aí na camada dois. A gente.
A aplicação.
Então você vai olhar todos os conteúdos. E aí você vai aplicar. Então tem um workshop de Ilhame Index para Reggae.
Para Reggae Fundo. Tem programa para Langshhen Langgraf.
Tem para Crewaii tem de n oito n.
Está faltando de Langfields. Que a gente vai fazer esse mês que vem e de Fi.
Tá? Que talvez mude. Não deixe de falho. Talvez mude aqui para um workshop que eu acho mais recente de Tecnologia Mas Langfields E Deep Ball.
Com certeza. Ou seja, você aprender. Olha só o nível. Você aprendeu na camada um, o que é evolve.
Você vai ver um workshop só de volta.
Como implementar um caso de uso com Langfils e Deep vol.
Aí. Depois a gente vai pra camada três.
De integração. Então veja que o booticamp já está aqui para você.
A gente teve um boot Camp que já foi gravado também há uns quatro, cinco meses atrás, que é totalmente Relevante No Caso De Uso De Cloud Que Usa Tudo Sobre Cloud.
Basically que vem, a gente vai ter o de codecs.
E Eu Acredito Muito Que A Gente Não Vai Ter De Open Claw. Eu Vou Mudar Para Ou Eu Vou mudar para Grok Bot. Eu vou mudar para Hermes, que é mais recente que eu. Acho que é uma parada muito foda de vocês terem.
E a gente tem a comunidade.
Então assim você vai acabar tendo tudo num lugar só. Então.
Quando vocês forem transbordar para a nova plataforma.
Você vai ter uma comunidade só para isso.
Então o que eu acredito que seja para você. Pô, eu quero aprender isso realmente no detalhe.
Eu quero entender isso realmente tá.
A gente deixou.
O desconto aqui para vocês.
Então, qual é o desconto?
E aí isso não acontece de novo, tá? Então, só para vocês saberem que isso não acontece de novo, eu vou deixar aqui.
O Link.
Para vocês que é o Qr Code para vocês acessarem.
Vocês vão falar com a mãe.
A mais ter informação de todo mundo que comprou.
E aí você que adquiriu o Boot Camp. Olha só.
Você que adquiriu o boot Camp.
Vai conseguir usar o valor.
Para poder adquirir a formação.
Então assim você não vai ter uma outra chance se não for essa.
Cara. Quero aprender realmente. Ai, native.
Com setenta horas de conteúdo.
Já tem muita gente, inclusive quem é aqui da formação. Acho que tem uma galera aqui da formação.
Isso aí.
Então aqui você tem todo o negócio.
E eu recomendo. Foi porque eu gravei. Não, mas tem muito Nugget.
Muito Nugget. Então, cara.
Obrigado. Por quem?
Todos conteúdos, tá? Então aproveitem. E aí?
Aqui embaixo.
Quem quiser se candidatar, quem tiver interesse.
De entrar na lista.
De ser um mentorado. Meu, adoro falar isso.
Você pode se candidatar agora, tá.
Então, basicamente, você pode assinar para dois mil e vinte e sete. Esse é o meu programa de mentoria, que Acontece Uma Vez Por Ano Inicialmente.
Que são entre quarenta, trinta, quarenta profissionais todo ano.
E eu passo um ano com essas pessoas dentro de um grupo no Whatsapp.
Tendo trocas. Tudo. Que acontece primeiro acontece com eles.
E uma coisa legal do Datasip. Tem alguém aqui do Datasip? Com certeza. Tem, né?
Uma das coisas que eu sempre falo do Datasip, que é um programa, não só de eu estar perto de Você Que é Muito Foda Mas Tem Outra Coisa Também Que é Indiscutível.
Tudo. Tudo que o Luan Moreno faz.
O Datasip Tank. Então, se eu lançar duzentos formações.
The Blumbers Mastering.
Ou que seja o que for, todo mundo do Datasip tem acesso. Então o programa que você.
Tudo o que eu lançar. Se eu lançar.
Um curso nos Estados Unidos de dois mil dólares. Como vai ser lançado? Pô, você tem acesso.
Então, sim, o Datasip vai continuar. Ele é o meu programa, literalmente anual.
De mentoria para eu mentorar. Vocês.
Laile dez mil vezes.
Beleza. Então é isso. Vou deixar aqui mais um minutinho. O código para quem tiver interesse.
De se inscrever na formação.
Time.
Se inscrevam.
Inclusive deixar a imagem.
Aqui. Pronto.
Beleza, beleza. Vamos ver como estão os nossos agentes.
Brincalhões e sorridentes aqui.
Outra coisa. Se vocês tiverem alguma dúvida da formação, alguma coisa? Pode perguntar aqui que eu tiro essa dúvida.
Olha lá. Começou a crencar as atividades inteiras, né?
Então, se a gente vier aqui em Docs Tasks.
O que abriu aqui? Meu Deus!
Jesus! Que medo!
Agora fiquei com medo.
Olá, coisa linda, né? Tipo, dois, tipo, três, tipo, quatro, tipo, cinco.
E ele está aqui, arregaçando.
Tá.
Então ele tem quatro passos aqui, né? Ele tô fazendo autoring das tarefas.
Fazer um apendem do Darkster. Vai fazer. O Nietzsche vai validar.
As atividades vão começar a aumentar ainda mais aqui, né?
Use Adrs.
E aí a vida está linda. A gente está conversando.
E a parada está crancando, né.
Hora de perguntas. Por que vocês não perguntam? Vocês têm para a gente conversar, tirar dúvida.
Porque a parada está fazendo aqui? A gente vai daqui a pouco verificar o resultado disso tudo.
Qual foi seu racional para escolher o Crisp em vez de gravador do Notion.
Porque eu já uso Crisp.
é meio que preguiça mesmo de Mud.
Eu tenho. Que agonia!
Da parada que fica tipo note fazendo a nota de alguma forma. Assim.
Coisa de velho. Mesmo.
Nada demais, tá?
Ló. Eu tô no Age, mas atrasado no conteúdo, com uma sequência pós buscampinha, implementar tudo ou aumentar o entendimento. Primeiro.
Cara, assim. ó.
Vou te falar o que eu faria? A primeira.
A primeira vontade é você pegar e sair implementando.
Mas eu não faria.
Eu.
Eu primeiro olharia os fundamentos da formação.
Porque eles vão te dar a base para que quando você olhe. E aí, olha só quando você olhe a Formação Quando Você Olha O Boticamp De Novo.
Você já olha com um olho diferente.
E assim a gente não está falando de duzentos horas de conteúdo. A gente tá falando, cara. Aqui você tem.
Você tem? Sei lá, doze, treze horas de conteúdo gravado.
Talvez, mas você não precisa ver tudo. Por exemplo.
Para esse tipo de entendimento. Tem coisas sendo para você ver.
Se eu preciso ver, por exemplo. Já vou te falar. O último. O último sempre.
Que o último fala de tendências futuro.
Mas é pouco também o final das contas.
Assim. Eu assistiria tudo. Tiraria notas, faria perguntas, inclusive a Júlia está aí.
A Júlia fez uma parada muito foda. Vamos.
Aplaudir. A Júlia criou um Mcp.
Com todos os conteúdos.
Que você tem para fazer? Pergunta em linguagem natural.
Então, quem é da formação? Vai ter isso.
Júlia, você pode falar. Vou te colocar no spot aqui. Mas se você puder falar.
Se eu quiser explicar um pouquinho, cara, ficou muito foda, velho.
O que ela fez. Falou assim.
Ficou foda. Realmente ficou, foda. Se ela quiser falar um pouquinho como ela fez, se ela puder, não sei se Ela Tá Podendo Mas Se Ela Não Puder.
Você está no mudo. Deixa eu ver se eu consigo desmudar você.
O que eu respiro um pouco na minha garganta. Aqui.
Levanta a mão aí. Rampão.
Então eu consigo tirar.
Levanta a mão.
I beleza. Diu, pode falar.
Oi, gente. Tudo bem, gente, por favor, usem o Lcp que dê um trabalho. Foi um trabalho maravilhoso para fazer E Ele Está Sensacional. A Saúde Da Base Está Maravilhosa Todos Os Conteúdos Que O Luan Deu Que O Rafael Deu.
Os workshops, os botiquampes. Tudo que vocês possam imaginar está lá? é só conectar um Mcp super simples. Vocês conectam No Cloud Ou No Cursor Na Ia Que Vocês Usam E Só Fazer Pergunta Que Ele Traz Para Vocês A Resposta.
Não só isso, tá? Vocês conectando com.
E meio de vocês pode ser via Google, ou ele vai solicitar um link mágico para vocês, para gerar, porque Tem Que Ser O E Mail De Compra Necessariamente.
Ele traz para vocês também a progressão de vocês no curso. Qual é a próxima aula que você está.
Que está faltando. Ele traz também conteúdos de fora de uma base externa para poder complementar.
A aula que você está. O assunto que você está fazendo? Então assim.
Tá maravilhoso. Eu não estou me capando. Não tá gente, porque eu fiz. Não porque realmente tá bom.
Aprendeu com o mestre, né, velho.
Mentira.
Aprendi com quem? Com o Luan Moriano.
Ela fez tudo. Ela fez tudo e só chegou assim. ó.
é isso aqui. Eu falei caralho.
Tá? E como não tá aqui.
E assim tá assim. E a qualidade tá? Assim.
Então é isso. Transformou a necessidade de um produto.
Ou seja, você tem todos como funciona, tio? Como que a gente faz internamente. Explica rapidamente como funciona.
Você está falando? O processo por dentro. Como funciona? Por trás.
Você está falando? Ah, então a gente pega as aulas, né? Quebra elas em Chunks.
Aí tem um limite que eu coloquei. Mais ou menos cem. Tem uma parte também que ele cobre.
Porque como quebra, pode quebrar em cima do.
The do Kilom está falando, e aí pode perder o contexto ali, nesse sentido. Então ela tem uma. Ela complementa Um Pouco Em Cima.
Isso tudo sobre com uma base nossa do Supabase.
E lá elas são taguadas. Então, o que vem de fora da base é tagada como data source. E o Que é De Dentro Das Aulas é Tagado Como Aula Mesmo.
E aí, quando vocês perguntam.
Ele faz essa pesquisa.
Lá com base nesses pedaços lá, que estão quebrados e está guiados. E aí ele traz a resposta para vocês. Tem O Reggae Tem Uma Base Vetorial Então Assim Está Bem Completo Mesmo A Estrutura.
Muito bem vindo.
E você ainda botou um woof ainda, né? De autenticação em cima disso pelo superbase, não foi.
Exatamente.
Em cima disso. é isso que eu estou falando. Aí vocês podem autenticar tanto. Via Google.
Ou pode também autenticar com o e mail. é porque assim eu botei as duas maneiras.
Porque não necessariamente. O meio de compra de vocês é o e mail da Google. Então eu botei o outro E Mail Com Um Link Mágico Também Para Vocês Receberem Mas O Wall Para O Google Direto Colocou.
Entrou com a conta Google. Você já pode usar.
é. é isso.
Eu acho que é do caralho. Então assim você vê.
E aí você tem um Mcp para fazer perguntas para tirar dúvida. Ele vai te dar a próxima progressão que Você Vai Assistir Enfim.
Então assim, cara, você tem todo esse conhecimento já embutido lá dentro, sabe.
E ele ainda dá a fonte da aula. Ou seja, no final, ele diz para você onde está a aula? Qual O Módulo Que Está E Qual é O Vídeo Ele Está Tudo Explicadinho.
Danada Dá Danada.
é? Não acredito. Não dá.
Fala assim, infelizmente, né.
Eh? Da última vez você chamou de Capilo. Sem rápido, mas tá tudo certo.
é que você se superou?
Então agora a gente vai ter uma utilização maior de ó.
Ele trabalhou durante catorze minutos.
E aí? Olha só.
O Cvg vai entrar aqui agora, rasgando para vocês verem.
Olha só. Que legal. Agora é a hora do foda, hein?
Ou não. Então ele cria.
Umas informações.
Internas.
Aí ele cria uma pasta chamada Cvg.
Essa parte. Essa é a página. Essa é a pasta do Converge.
Então ele tem o Brem.
Que ele vai começar a fazer essas informações e trazer para você.
Ele tem uns docs.
Que ele vai começar a colocar essas informações para você.
Ele tem as execuções que foram feitas. Eles têm as receitas de aprendizado.
Ele tem a Swim Lenes que foram feitas.
Cortadas aí. Ele já cortou bonitinho aqui.
E ele tem as tarefas que vão ser executadas.
Então, basicamente, quando você usa a esteca inteiras do Cvos.
Ele vai guardar tudo isso dentro de um Cvg Folder para a gente.
E a gente vai ter toda essa informação.
Ele vai guardando experiencias. Ele tem lições. A gente vai ver um pouquinho mais amanhã.
Com a fábrica.
Então ele criou modern.
Ingestam Src. No Afunday. Como.
Ele criou um como.
Types.
Cut those types.
Hmm, tariff.
Ah, ele não executou tarefa de fazer amanhã.
é isto mesmo.
Não para! Eu não quero fazer Bora.
Eu quero só deixar elas preparadas para a gente fazer amanhã na fábrica.
Vai ser melhor.
Mesh crank.
Na verdade, agora a gente gerou aquilo.
Agora a gente vai utilizar. O Mesh, vamos ver se ele vai funcionar.
Passe oito.
Vamos executar.
Tipo um.
Fim, a fim.
Então a gente vai fazer o Crank de todas as tarefas do tipo um para verificar se existe alguma coisa Que Ainda Não Foi Feita Tá.
Utilizando o Taskmash, que é a Indign que eu falei para vocês por debaixo dos panos.
Então lembra que a gente criou um contrato aqui, né? Então, toda vez que você gera uma tarefa.
Você tem um contrato que é gerado justamente com ela.
E aí, o que o Test Match vai fazer, né? Testmash? Ele é in Chinese.
Dentro. Antigamente, essa Indign não ficava. Ela ficava só.
No converge.
O que eu fiz na verdade, foi fazer o quê? Foi pegar isso.
E trazer para o Task Spec para dar para vocês um looping.
De execução dentro do Taskmash dentro do Task Spec. Porque eu falei pô.
Eu já tenho tudo isso acontecendo dentro. Task Spec, né?
Por que eu não gero looping para fazer isso? E gero um Engen multipada.
Então gerei uma higiene multifacetada para poder fazer isso e escrever tudo isso para vocês. Tá.
Então, basicamente, isso que ela faz.
Então a gente vai fazer o cranking dela.
A gente vai executar o tipo. Um fim a fim no loop.
Se já não tivesse sido executada.
Como todo estiver faltando os pedaços finais, que é a parte do Darkstey e do Serving.
A gente vai fazer isso e a gente vai ver o pacote final. Fim a fim.
Dela sendo executada.
Então a ideia é que, por exemplo, se a gente vier aqui, ó.
Dentro de Docs.
Adrs. A gente gerou duas Adrs novas. Tá vendo?
A doze. Dexter, ao Linnet.
Então, falando um pouquinho, que ele vai ser o Liner para a gente ver o passo a passo inteiro.
E o Fast Api para a gente acessar essas informações via Mcp, para que a Marina, para que a Helena Possa Perguntar Essas Informações.
Para a gente, entendeu?
Muito doido. Isso aqui, cara.
Então o que ele vai fazer é executar por sm dining para a gente ver.
Failed. Vamos ver porque que falhou.
I'm Coming.
Que falhou. Ninguém executando comigo aí.
Queria que vocês acompanhassem.
Bom que agora a gente vai para o processo Trouble Shooting.
Vamos fazer um turbo shooting aqui.
Mhm.
Opa, Rafael, tá comigo aí.
O Rafael. Tá, nível louco.
Legal.
A tendência não existe. A gente não tem evidência.
Boa.
Let me falar aqui pra mim.
No meu caso, eu só tive que fazer aprovação.
Dar o Stamping, né.
Vamos ver se ele vai aceitar.
é porque é aquela coisa, né.
Você não sabe se você segue se você para se você vai, se você não vai.
Porque você quer prestar atenção.
Eu entendo isso.
E assim eu gosto. Eu particularmente. Luana, eu gosto de prestar atenção.
E depois.
Fazer. Mas é como eu gosto, né? Cada pessoa é de um jeito.
Alguém que já testou o Glm cinco dois.
Cinco, três, cinco, dois e cinco, três.
Algumas cara que é tanta versão. Meu irmão.
Cinco, dois. Alguém já testou?
Claro. Amanhã tem cervejinha.
Bem o que vocês quiserem.
Com certeza.
Aprovação.
Agora ele vai. Ele vai escrever o loop para a gente poder fazer. Vamos pegar cinco minutos de recreio para Eu Poder Ir No Banheiro.
Porra, Macalan, dezoito anos. Aí tu. Tá bem.
Caraca. Agora.
Até eu fiquei com inveja.
Não, cara. Eu acho que o Glm é cinco dois. Eu tava vendo aqui. Agora.
Cinco, três. Não, acho que assim é.
Tem aqui o Flash.
Slm. Cinco tres. Tá certo. é Glm.
Glni!
Cinco ponto. Cadê.
Models.
Tem esse aqui, né? Hoje eu me sinto ponto.
Três flash.
Mas não sei se tem ele de fato.
Eu não usei ele bastante, mas queria saber se alguém já usou.
Para falar. Pô, é muito bom.
Beleza. Pessoal, vamos voltar daqui.
Ceox cinco três. Foi sinistro, né?
Vamos voltar. Dez e quarenta e dois, tá? Deixa eu só ir no banheiro.
E gargarejar aqui. Eu já volto.
Enquanto ele está executando aqui os Gates.
Galera. Notícia boa que está acabando. Notícia ruim.
They came. A garganta.
Já foi. Já.
Tá. Vamos lá.
Estava, assinala.
Who look tá aqui.
Próximo passo é Stage T. Package skip data hash.
Let's Go. Isso é vibe coding.
Chegou a hora que você está desse jeito. Já o Let S Go.
Bora.
Então o que na verdade ele fez? Ele vai explicar aqui.
O tipo um. Ele foi gaitado, né? E crancado gaitado. Porque a gente fez o Stamping de falar. Isso mesmo. A gente quer.
Então ele fez um Task Spec gate.
No Tier I no hate Mec, para selar essa atividade.
Essa atividade do Landing. Passe.
E agora o cartão pode mover.
E a gente.
Trabalhar a execução desse cara.
Eles vão começar a trabalhar agora.
Todas as atividades.
Que estão faltando.
Então, nesse caso, a gente vai fazer o cranking de uma tarefa.
E depois a gente vai literalmente verificar.
O zero um inteiro, né?
Então I say day.
Então no seis, aqui, ó.
A gente vai.
Mesh crank that says the ran.
Ao do Leaf.
Beleza. E no seis.
A gente faz o pacote.
De olhar a evidência. E agora, de fato, executar esse cara.
Nós estamos no cinco.
Na verdade, teria que executar.
Esse é o teu cinco, né?
Vamos dar um Steer aqui.
Pronto para executar. Certinho. Porque se ele pode não executar o certo.
Mas ele vai, né? Mas ele vai ficar loop.
De vinte e seis. Então deixa eu abrir aqui. Docs tasks.
Ele vai botar o Tagster.
E aí a gente vai deixar ele Unattendant, né?
Executando ele.
Até.
O processo que a gente vai chamar de Half Even, né?
Que vai ser basicamente o contrato do Java, dizendo que a gente vai conseguir executar.
Até a metade dele dos Defects para achar que ele sentava.
Errado. Então a gente quer bater nesses dois. Então a gente vai executar o setenta e oito para isso.
E aí? Amanhã?
Lembra que a gente teve.
Os pedaços criados mas não executados, né.
Que amanhã ainda não acabou. Mas eu quero rodar algumas outras táticas, né?
Eu vou deixar isso no Línea configurado, rodando.
Eu vou mostrar memória. Eu vou mostrar Flywhew.
De como a gente vai coletar.
Como a gente vai coletar as lições. E daí?
Criar Skills para resolver os problemas. Então a gente vai entender aqui que existe um problema financeiro.
E a gente vai identificar esse problema. Vai criar uma Skill para corrigir. E vai corrigir esse problema.
Então é isso que a gente vai fazer.
Eu deixei algumas queries para vocês fazerem.
Para vocês entrarem nas especificidades para vocês entenderem o que vai ser falado amanhã.
Qual o conceito de Flywhew.
Qual é o conceito de.
De memória que a gente vai usar. O que significa restate.
O que é recall. Então quero que vocês façam algumas perguntinhas.
Tá? Para a gente poder executar.
Inclusive um novo tipo.
A média. Executar um tipo que nunca foi visto.
Que é o tipo seis.
Ou seja, não existe nenhum entendimento do que é esse tipo. A gente não conhece esse tipo. A gente não Entende Absolutamente Nada Desse Tipo A Gente Não Sabe Nada Sobre Ele.
Então a gente vai colocar amanhã. A gente vai automatizar a fábrica amanhã.
E depois a gente vai criar.
Vai chegar esse novo tipo para a gente. E a gente só vai falar o seguinte, Fábio, que executa.
E daí vocês vão ver exatamente.
Como a fábrica funciona.
Essa é a grande questão.
Como deixar todos esses processos automatizados um atrás do outro, ciclando hino.
All the way.
Beneath Them foi.
Executor. Dexi.
Vamos ver aqui.
Ele criou, né? Agora a gente vai.
Seis. A gente fez lookup package.
Também. Cut Package.
A gente vai, tipo, cinco.
Eu vou deixar. Espero que vocês façam mesmo. Tá.
Quero que vocês deixem o tipo cinco aqui, executando.
Então.
Executar o cenário tipo assim. Fim a fim.
Depois a gente vai abrir esse tipo cinco.
E validar o que ele é.
E eu vou deixar ele rodando aqui, porque ele vai demorar aproximadamente uns vinte, trinta minutos para eu poder fazer Todo O Processo Que Agora Ele Vai Entender.
O tipo cinco inteiro.
E eu quero mostrar. Eu não vou.
Amanhã. Eu vou deixar os pontos do que foi criado para mostrar para vocês o que foi feito.
Mas agora.
A gente vai ver que o Tipo cinco foi criado. Está vendo, tipo quatro foi criado. Essas atividades foram criadas. Elas Ainda Não Foram Executadas.
Mas agora a gente vai criar toda essa parte da criação das tarefas para o tipo cinco.
Porque se a gente vê aqui em Docs.
Tasks. Tá vendo? A gente tem. ó.
Tipo um tipo dois.
Tipo três, tipo, quatro e, tipo, cinco. Agora, eu quero executar esse cara. Fim do tipo cinco.
E depois aplicar o cenário para validar se esse tipo cinco que a gente fez baixo, a gente vai investigar esse tipo cinco.
E verificar na mão se realmente ele está batendo com a evidência.
E na sexta feira, a gente vai aprender.
Como automatizar tudo isso. Ou seja, cai uma nova requisição no seu projeto.
Por exemplo, aqui vai chegar um novo tipo aqui.
Vai chegar ao Tipo seis aqui amanhã.
E daí? A gente vai simplesmente rodar esse cara.
Beleza.
E aí?
Melhor hoje. Um pouco mais claro. Fizemos várias coisas diferentes hoje. Também.
Gente. Eu vou guardar minha garganta.
Para amanhã.
A ideia é que você possa generalizar Jonathan. Isso.
Tá então aqui eu peguei um caso de se você olhar. A gente pegou.
Três casos aqui, né? ó.
E isso é uma pergunta relevante.
Se você olhar o que a gente pegou aqui de casa de uso, a gente pegou um caso de engenharia De Software Então A Gente Já Viu Que Ele Decompõe Escreve De Java Para Python.
A gente pegou um caso de Date Engineering.
Que pega toda a parte de pipeline de dados de compõe, escreve.
A gente pegou a parte de Analytics e Engineering que pega toda a camada de Gold e cria.
Também toda a visão de Dbt e lógica na Goug.
E a gente pegou também ai Engineering.
Que foi criar o Mcp.
E criar toda a conexão com a base para o usuário poder usar Vmcp que a gente vai usar no final.
Então a gente viu quatro.
Pela lente de um caso de urso. A gente viu quatro.
Approaches diferentes.
Então isso. Acho que isso é bem legal para você ver que.
Nesses quatro casos, funcionam muito bem.
Tá.
Beleza. E aí, gente, só dar o final pra gente.
Gostaram? Foi foda hoje.
Curtiram. Deixa vocês executando. Tenta todo mundo amanhã.
Fazer isso inclusive. Obrigado. Vou perguntar. Ju.
Amanhã começa às sete horas e eu preciso terminar um pouquinho antes das dez.
Porque eu pego o voo uma da manhã.
Dez, onze, doze. Eu pego duas da manhã.
Então.
Eu vou precisar começar. Sete, sete, dez. E a gente começa. Eu vou ter umas nove, quarenta.
Nove, cinquenta, nove, nove. Alguma coisa? Beleza.
Então tá bom. Aguardo vocês amanhã, gente, obrigado. Espero que vocês tenham curtido bastante.
Obrigado aí, por todos os culminários. Obrigado a todo mundo que ficou até aí, que acompanhou.
é o processo. é só por osmose. às vezes, a gente aprende realmente de estar no ambiente.
Obrigado, minha gaveta. Já estão sessenta aqui. De que amanhã eu vou estar cem. Tá.
Japonês, pessoal. Até amanhã.